foreign
you
today
liberty and justice for all
some more
of the schedules
thank you chairman thank you
representatives i'm here to present hb
a bill that i always refer to as the
a4plex is a house bill
and the reason a fourplex is a house is
because that's what
the
federal loan agencies regarded as new
hampshire has a housing crisis
we all know that we are at least 20 000
units short and have been for some time
when i was a newspaper reporter in 1984
one of the things that i remember
covering
was amherst new hampshire's
panic about the fact that they could not
field a fire department
because no one could afford to live in
town and work in town who's also served
on the fire department but they couldn't
afford to live in town because it was
too expensive so this is a thing that
i've been hearing people talk about for
38 years and we have not made much
progress
and
what i'm hoping to do with this bill
is to allow gradual increases
of residential units in neighborhoods
that are served by municipal water and
sewer this bill doesn't have anything to
do with places out in the country that
have a well and septic
doesn't have anything to do with three
lot subdivisions with well and septic
this is only places that already exist
that have water and sewer provided by
the municipality and already existing
roads and the roads are a thing
because it cost four dollars and
sixty-five cents a center-line foot
to salt sand plowed ditch and mow
a foot of town-owned land and that's
pretty generally true across the state i
checked with the d.o.t
so if we can use those roads we already
have
that's a better deal for
everyone so 20 000 units short how did
we get here
we got here because over the last 50
years or maybe even 75 we've
artificially constrained the production
of housing and we have privileged the
production of two kinds of housing only
single-family houses
and big apartment complexes those are
the things that we've made it easy to
build and we've made it easier to build
single-family residences than apartment
complexes
so what we have is we have a lot of
single-family and some big apartment
complexes and nothing in the middle
in my day job i'm a i'm an urban planner
and we talk a lot about what we call the
missing middle and that's
everything between a duplex and a small
apartment building duplexes triples
quads
cottage courts
dignified small apartment buildings we
used to build those because financially
they make a lot of sense and if you look
at any established neighborhood
in any city you'll see examples of those
things
sometimes you can't tell that they're
not a single family house
but our zoning has made it really hard
not to say impossible to build any more
of this
so part of our housing crisis is caused
by down zoning making it impossible to
build anything except a single-family
residence more than 75 percent of
nashua's land area is zoned
single-family only
the other part of it some so some
some was intended but some of it was
intended but didn't work out the way we
thought sometimes places required larger
lots because they were worried about
having more kids in school
and that meant that you got bigger
houses on bigger lots and they cost more
money and they still cost more money
so
we've frozen these places that are
served by water and tour and sewer so
that they can't change whatever that's
there now is all that there can be what
this bill would do
is
re-legalize
up to four units only four that's a
house the fha thinks it's a house
it's a house it's house sized
the bill also makes it clear that
the buildings that could be newly
constructed under this bill have to
abide by the same rules as a single
family house
so if your zoning code says
that the setbacks for a single family
house are
10 feet on each side and 30 feet at the
back and whatever it is in the front if
you build a fourplex it would have to
revive by the same rules or a duplex or
a triple
if you have 30 lot coverage you have to
have you can't have more than 30 lot
coverage
with a with a
building that has more units
and what about the parking
the parking is is geared to the dwelling
unit number
so that if your code says that for every
dwelling unit you have to have as one
space or a space and a half or two
spaces then a a duplex a triple and a
quad would have to have two three or
four times that number
and you're gonna have to figure out how
to get that on the parcel
um
so this bill legalizes missing middle
housing by making up to four units
permissible by right on any
residentially zoned lot with municipal
water and sewer
just like all of our favorite
neighborhoods
part of the reason that our favorite
neighborhoods are wildly expensive
is because we stopped building them we
made it illegal to build them
people want to live
in proximity if that's what they want
and we had we don't have enough of it we
have enough of things out in the country
but we don't have enough things where i
can walk to the corner store and buy a
quart of milk where i can let my child
ride their bicycle to
the corner store and get a popsicle and
get home before it melts we don't have
enough of that and that makes those
places that do exist
really really expensive
and it's pressure from both ends of the
demographics people my age want that
people my kids age want that people in
the middle want that
and we need to make that happen we need
to let that happen in a way that is
incremental
and will not disrupt the fabric
of the neighborhood
and let's talk about demographics for a
minute we have a big
number of big single-family houses we
don't have a lot of anything else except
you know big apartment complexes which
i think most of us are in agreement that
we don't want a lot of those in our
downtown maybe not even any
and
right now
within the next five years 75 of all
households in the united states are
going to be one and two-person
households
there are
already fewer than one-fifth 20
of all households have
children in school
so we're becoming a nation of smaller
households with fewer children and we
have not kept up
in our building to meet that need in any
way we just haven't and as i said when i
started this is a conversation we've
been having
for
in my ears 38 years
we need to do something
is this going to solve all our housing
problems
no but it does give us
another tool
to use
now
i know the big question is
you know we don't like telling towns
what they have to do
sometimes there is a reason
to support preemptive zoning
we have preemptive we have pre-emptive
state rules about wastewater water
quality protection of shorelands and
lake fronts
we have all of those rules
we have statewide rules about car safety
i would submit that given
our situation and this is true across
the united states our situation
vis-a-vis housing
it's time for the state to say hey we
need to do something about this
if we leave it up to the individual
towns there's absolutely no incentive
for any one town
to do this because
it's too hard
one town at a time the response is going
to be well why should we allow this
those people over in that town over
there they don't allow it why should we
do it why is it so important for us to
do it
we've tried hard over the last 20 years
to do this
one town at a time and we have been
remarkably unsuccessful
1177 merely says okay
you need to allow
house-sized buildings with up to four
units in places that already exist with
water and sewer and roads it's another
tool
in an effort to get
more housing in new hampshire
the other advantage of a fourplex or a
triple or a duplex is they're much more
likely to be owner-occupied
it's a size that doesn't appeal to big
developers there's not enough juice for
the squeeze
it's a it's a size that appeals to
people who want to work in their own
town or the next town over two women in
a pickup truck can build a four-plex
a little old lady can convert her house
to three units
this is a thing that empowers
individuals
and
creates
better outcomes for everyone this is a
bill for
businesses who are looking for housing
for their workers this is a bill for
people who are living in a house that's
too big for them
this is a bill for people who want to
create a little property that they can
rent out
part of and live in the other half of
this is a bill that works for a lot of
people
and as i said
these buildings already exist
in every place in new hampshire i was
driving through richmond the other day
richmond population i think a thousand
there's a fourplex right on the corner
in richmond i stopped to take a picture
because i always do
but they're everywhere and often you
can't even tell it's a multi-family
until you go around to the side and
count the electric meters
that's how you tell
so in conclusion i ask you to support hp
1177 of fourplex is a house
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
is this bill
intent to create rentals
i suppose that some of them would be
rentals yes
follow up please
well if it's
individually owned
does is that going to require
subdivision of the lot
no because what this says is if that
would be a condo and that's a different
animal altogether and those have to
abide by the condo rules what this says
is that if you have
a lot an existing lot and you can under
the constraints of whatever your local
zoning is
build a building or two buildings or
four little tiny buildings
that meet those constraints you can put
you can put that on that lot
does that help
follow please
so these would be individually owned
properties
or dwellings on a single lot
no
my guess is no because that would
require subdivision and then you have to
abide by your subdivision rules what
this does is if i have a big house
that's too big for me
right now in the town i live in if i
wanted to make a duplex my house suppose
suppose my house were on a half an acre
in my town in order to turn that house
into a duplex i would have to have a
whole acre of land what this bill says
is
no you can make a duplex out of that
building or you can make a three or a
four if you abide by the setbacks lot
coverage and parking required in your
town
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
would you believe that this also answers
uh
some of the needs like for example in
our case
we looked at downsizing we have a larger
home
and
we wanted to downsize and i wanted to
stay in our own ward
if in order for us to downsize get
something smaller i almost have to pay
the same amount that my house is worth
so it didn't make any sense to go
smaller and lose the equity that we have
and we do have opportunity to do at
least two
you know like they would create in my
neighborhood they have created uh in la
apartments
yeah
yes
she did she asked me
i do believe that i will say that as
probably all of you know i did exactly
that in my house i put my roof where my
mouth was i created three units out of
what had been one enormous dumb
victorian so yes and one of the things
that i'd like to add to that is because
these tend to be small things they are
often owner occupied
which
we don't require owner occupancy
and we shouldn't
there's no legal justification for it
but i know that people feel better
about knowing that their landlord is
right there
follow-up mr chair yeah so what this my
requirement is like you know i get a
call all the time to host a
student or you know in the past we have
done that if they were part of my
household that became too much
so now to create an independent small
unit
helps not only helps us knowing that we
are supporting somebody and also helps
us stay in our own home rent it out
not an exorbitant but at least to pay
for
some of the utilities
so that's a win-win
i think it is yes thank you so would you
believe that it would be a great
addition
i do believe that and and it's a great
addition as i said in my testimony for
all kinds of people i mean we just we
need housing we need housing choices and
this by the way does not preclude you
from building a single family house
it's not the end of single family houses
you can build a single family house
you just have other choices available to
you
thank you uh mr chairman and i promise
not to ask a question about parking
um i i do have two questions uh mr
chairman but uh the first one you've
kind of answered it already you said it
does there's no owner owned requirement
but adus have an owner-owned requirement
this is different in which way thank you
adus when we drafted the adu ordinance
one of the things that is in the adu
statute says that local jurisdictions
may
they don't have to but they may require
owner occupancy for an adu this does not
have any such requirement
and just one other question mr chairman
thank you so much
my other question is
anytime we consider
multi-units of five or more we always
think of them as commercial and
um in apartment type of styles this
falls below that but one of the nice
things about that other thing is that we
have the ability of code enforcement
um because a
private home
has different code enforcements actually
none
versus a apartment type conflict so how
does the code enforcement
for these where they're not commercial
work differently
well in terms of the building code more
than two units
falls under the international building
code which is the the code that's used
for commercial buildings to or below are
in the residential code
so depending on whether it's two three
or four your local code enforcement
officer uses the code
for
that type of building so a duplex they
use the international residential code
which governs things like how tall your
stair risers have to be
and
anything above three or above requires
sprinkling in the state of new hampshire
that's part of the ibc the international
building code in new hampshire so there
are still all the all the relevant fire
and safety and building construction
rules apply
can i just ask for one quick
clarification sir thank you
thank you and and i'm just glad to hear
that that the the question would be more
like um for instance now
in nashua if someone had um
bed bugs or uh uh
a a window that wasn't opening properly
they can call code and they come and
check it because it's commercial would
that still apply to this i think that's
a local control issue i think that you
could you can add that to if you want to
say
you know three and above now falls under
that that would be up to you locally
this bill does not address that my
assumption is that that would fall under
health and safety just like any place
else i mean for example if i remodel a
single family home and i have a bedroom
and i rent it out and it turns out that
one of the windows is not big enough for
an egress window
that's an issue that can be dealt with
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um in my community of merrimack we have
many single-family homes
that have in-law apartments
um
you really can't tell unless you know
the person's there
how how does this fit in would that
allow in-law apartments to be
you know rented by other people or
because right now i think i don't know
if it's a state law or an ordinance but
only family can use an in-law apartment
right
what your town has done is they have
adopted an accessory dwelling unit
ordinance that requires owner occupancy
or family connection
that's a choice that local jurisdictions
can make
if you build if you make it a duplex
then the adu ordinances don't require so
don't affect it so it depends on how the
building owner
goes about doing it if you
are explicitly building an adu and you
are asking to have an adu then you have
to abide by the adu rules if you go down
to the code office and you say i'd like
to have another unit
and they say do you want an adu or do
you want a duplex and then you say i
want a duplex then the duplex rules
would apply under this under this
statute
so it's a difference of what your local
jurisdiction has done
good morning representative
i come from a community that has a
master plan
we've identified the number of losses
one acre half acre and part of that
master plan is uh
it kind of tells us what direction we're
going to go with our sewer and water and
development things like that so we know
we've got 10 one acre lots gonna have
ten houses
now if your bill passed
we could potentially have 40 houses or
40 residents on those 10 acre lots
which should be
kind of pushing our sewer system where
we could have to spend 10 15 20 million
dollars to accommodate that change
how do you explain that that difference
how does that work into this i guess
so
uh you can't do this unless you have
municipal water and sewer so if there's
not municipal water and sewer to those
lots now
or the developer is not willing to
extend it
and and the town agrees that they have
capacity then they can't do it so
primarily this is intended as infill
rather than as sprawling out into the
countryside
so
you could as a town if your sewer and
water is pressed
you can say we can't approve these 40
new units
because it is premature we don't have
the sewer capacity
as i said this bill is intended to
address already existing lots served by
already existing water and sewer
representative melvin
thank you for
uh thank you for taking my question
uh
you've got an old victorian and you're
going to turn it into a four unit
structure
uh it have to be ada and have elevators
no
ada is a civil law
um and
you if you build a new building of i
think it's five or more
one of the ground floor units has to be
ada accessible
but this oh sorry
this law does not address that i mean
you don't have to put in elevators you
have to put in um you have to have
egress um you have to have an egress
path that's less than i think it's less
than 100 feet door your front door to
the outside uh you have to have egress
windows if it's more than two units it
has to be sprinkled
all of those fire and safety rules still
apply
but the ada rule is slightly different
because it's civil
it's that's under the fair housing act
and would not apply in this case in most
instances representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
presenting the bill
uh representative van
it just seems to be limited can you tell
me how many
uh cities and towns this would impact on
because like seems to me that we have an
awful lot of communities that don't that
have water but don't have sewer yes that
is absolutely true it is limited to
places that have water and sewer and
it's limited even in places that have
water and sewer usually only have it in
their village center so yeah this is
very much a bill that's limited to
places where that exists thank you thank
you president another follow-up
yes
thank you for uh
allowing me i have a question about uh
the uh line four of the
bill it says
to uh in which there are unin located
unincorporated towns or un organized
places
so
is this maine that say like in nashua
this bill would not apply
no that spoiler plate that ols puts in
that makes it cover all of the state
that's the way the subdivision right
this lives in the subdivision regulation
i think and that language lives there
everywhere so
no it does not mean that nashua would
not be included
it's all jurisdic that's just their way
of saying everywhere but as you read
further down it only applies where
there's municipal water and sewer
hello please
so this means that in nashua there are
located unincorporated
towns or unorganized places
no sir
that is for the whole state i asked ols
about this because i was confused and
they said that that's the description
for the whole state if you're writing an
ordinary statute that affects the whole
state under land use that's the language
you have to use and then as you come
down the bill or down the proposed bill
you see
it narrows down to only those places
with municipal water and sewer i mean i
suppose
given that language that if you were a
billionaire you could buy
i don't know 500 acres someplace put in
municipal water and sewer and use this
ordinance but existing unincorporated
places
uh would not be affected by this any
more than big subdivisions would be
affected by this it's places with
municipal water and sewer
thank you
representative matcha foodie
thank you mr chair uh
quick uh con
quick clarification
and you know i live in a neighborhood of
a you know would you believe that in a
small neighborhood like mine which is
only 35 homes if we each even 35 homes
which is a large half acre
lots
and about four homes have in the
apartment already
so even if we add because it has both
municipal water and sewer
and we have you know some of us have
three parking garages
or four
so this would suffi without adding
any stress on the public
utilities
correct
and this would be the infill of existing
yes this is intended for infill of
existing neighborhoods and this is not
going to transform us overnight i think
one of the things that people worry
about is that if you have an ordinance
like this a statute that requires this
that instantly everything is going to
change everything's not going to change
some people don't want to subdivide
their house some people don't want to
have that and they don't have to they're
not required to it's just another
tool one follow-up quick follow-up
so would you also believe that this will
encourage
multi-generational
existence without having to
move out and aging in place it would
allow me to age in my own home
yes and that's an interesting thing you
bring up it turns out that one of the
big movers and shakers behind this kind
of legislation which by the way includes
agencies or organizations as diverse as
the american association of required
tired persons and the american
enterprise institute all support this
kind of legislation and the reason that
the aarp likes it is because it does
allow you to stay in your own place
they've been big
proponents
of this kind of ordinance
okay
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question my
question pertains to line five where it
states as a matter of right any single
family lot
focusing on any single family lot
so if i have a single family lot of
sufficient acreage
under this bill would i be and i have a
home on that acreage would i then be
allowed to
construct new construction of four
single units on that lot
it's a total of four and it would depend
on what your local ordinance says about
setbacks
lot coverage and parking requirements as
to whether you could do it because you
have to abide by that
so if you have a lot that is big enough
to park however many
units you're proposing and you have
water and sewer and you can maintain the
setbacks and you can meet the coverage
requirements then yes you would be able
to and and i'd add that the goal here is
to make this straight forward for people
often people can do this
if they go and apply for a variance but
that's another step and since so many of
these conversions are done by the people
who live in them
it's that's a step that makes it more
complicated and they're likely to throw
up their hands and say you know this is
just too hard i can't do it
follow up mr chair yes go ahead thank
you
so um based on um your explanation
an owner of a single family lot may need
to subdivide that lot if that is
required by the town i mean no no
this explicitly says you're not you
don't have to subdivide this says
explicitly that one single lot not
subdivided can have up to four units
provided that you meet all of the other
zoning local zoning regulations
thank you representative ann for taking
my question
would you agree with me that if this was
made optional
that a
town
that made it optional and allowed this
sort of thing
and if it wasn't
a statewide rule
that if that was the only town that that
opted to do that
that they would be inundated
by
by developers wanting to take advantage
of that
and surrounding towns who opted not to
would be sitting there saying well look
you know it's your fault
uh yes i would completely believe that i
i don't think that this is going to
empower developers to do a whole lot
because as i said this is not a bill
that appeals to big developers
but
my own observation as a person who works
in this field
is that one of the problems with
proposing an ordinance change in any
given town to allow historically
appropriate density which is what this
is these buildings already exist in most
places
that the response from the
voters is why should we do this because
those guys over there aren't doing it
representative gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh last year we saw a
similar bill
um that mandated this uh
throughout the state uh you know
provided the water and sewer and the um
and the setbacks etcetera were provided
now it says uh
the local legislative
legislative body uh would enact this so
it's a local uh no this is a this is not
an enabling this is not an enabling bill
this is a preemptive bill
they shall
if it doesn't say that then i need
another amendment
because it's intended and because of the
reason i just explained to uh
representatives because one season two
one at a time doesn't work we've tried
one at a time for 40 years and it just
doesn't work thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative taking my question many
of us sit on planning boards here and
i'm looking to your expertise as it is
your
profession one of the things that we
consider is emergency services you'd
have to put in some type i assume with
this you'd have to put in some type of
access
to those structures you might have to
extend access
this bill would not limit the
authority of review of the emergency
service access to that
and then you know base the final
decision on whether or not they can or
cannot safely
evacuate people from that
that's absolutely correct that falls
under all those local rules
so for example if i wanted to build a
cottage court and i
have
structured it in such a way that the
buildings are too far from the street
i'm going to have to either put in a
hydrant or i'm going to have to you know
harden the sides of my narrow driveway
so that a fire truck can fit yes all
those things still apply
representative gallagher
i i
wasn't raising my hand um
or were you done
okay um all right so yeah
i'll testify then
well before we before we do that
representative tripp
uh
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh
back to uh line four it says that
a city town or county in which are
located on unincorporated places and
towns
uh
if the city doesn't have unincorporated
or una
grace
unorganized places
but the county does would that take
precedence
that's a question i would have to ask
ols as i said earlier i asked them why
that language was in there and they said
this is the way that we write it for any
bill that affects land use statutes
so i will ask my understanding is that
what this does is if a place later had
water and sewer
you know if it if it you know suddenly
had water and sewer this would apply
municipal water and sewer but that's
just the boilerplate language they used
to describe
land area in new hampshire i'll find out
and if we need to if we need an
amendment um i'm happy to offer one but
i'll check on it again for you thank you
representative gallagher
the testifier to ask a question uh to
ask a question
i think he only wants to testify yeah i
submitted the pink card because i wanted
to testify
okay
you know that if you testify then that
limits your ability to participate in
the discussion
um
yeah well i haven't asked any questions
so far so
um
i i'm aware of that
we what we do is
if if a member of the committee
testifies then when it comes when
that member is then limited to
any further discussion on the bill
you will be allowed to participate
completely at the executive session but
in the hearing
uh
that's when the limit takes effect
you still want to testify um
yeah
mr chairman i have a point of order
yes um
i i don't know if it's uh consistent
from committee to committee but are
co-sponsors allowed to
uh question during a public hearing or
just testify or do they have the choice
that was my
purpose in
questioning representative gallagher
no the answer to the question is no
that's why
it would not be proper for him to
question representative van
as a co-sponsor if he wants to
offer separate testimony okay thank you
thank you all very much for listening to
my ted talk i'm always happy to talk
about housing mr chair i have a question
for you
i'm a co-sponsor on this but i'm not
testifying but i can ask the questions
correct yes thank you
thank you all very much
go ahead representative gallagher
so
hi i'm
representative eric gallagher
of
merrimack county
district 15 that's concrete ward 6
which you can see right out the window
so
i am
i am sponsoring this bill
um
co-sponsoring this bill
due to um
the
many of the reasons
that representative fan
shared up i just wanted to testify to
share some of my
own personal experience
with fourplexes um
so
i grew up
i grew up here
in
new hampshire in a single family home
and i'm now living in one of those big
apartment complexes
my younger brother on the other hand
currently moved
currently
is living out in portland oregon and he
is actually living
in the fourplex
himself
currently
and um i actually went out to visit him
this fall and
you know it's a it's a very nice
um
it you know it's a very nice
living space and
um it
was pretty easy to
i wasn't actually able to stay with him
himself
but i was able to find a nearby airbnb
pretty easily
so um
yeah one of the reasons
he's living there instead of continuing
to live here is because he's able to
find housing there
so you know that's just an example of
how
new hampshire
is
losing out on
um
young dynamic members of our workforce
to other places that can
properly house them
so
if we want to
keep people like him in this state we
should
provide proper housing for them and pass
this
fourplex bell
um
and
um yeah i'll
take any questions about
any questions what it's like
thank you for your testimony
thank you
next we have uh
chet clem
from west lebanon
good morning
my name is chuck clem with lime
properties based in west lebanon new
hampshire
we're a development company that does
master planning of community conscious
development projects that also dovetails
closely with downtown revitalization
efforts which i've been working on with
representative laurel davis for the past
year
i'm here to testify in support of
representative van's bill which enables
the kind of smart growth that our city
and town centers need as we look to
reinvest in the next era of new
hampshire and address a housing shortage
that is limiting our economic growth in
the upper valley
i'm speaking as a developer but i want
to emphasize rep van's point that this
is about making the development of
housing approachable to everyone
i'm an aspirational missing middle
housing developer
i say aspirational because i'm currently
prohibited from developing the type of
housing we're talking about today
on property that i own in west lebanon
that is already served by water and
sewer infrastructure
central to the idea of smart growth is
the idea of maximizing the use of that
existing infrastructure
but as our land use policy and approval
stand today
i can build one unit
or i can build 125 units but i can't do
anything in the middle
i've spent months and thousands of
dollars trying to
only to have it shot down because of
old thinking around smart neighborhood
specific density
i'm going to try again this year to
propose neighborhood appropriate density
that takes advantage of that shared
infrastructure access to public transit
and creates the kind of housing that
people keep showing up at my office
telling me they want
you can look to municipalities elsewhere
in the country that are effectively
deploying policies like that which
representative anne has proposed today
but you can also just look at our own
towns and cities where this typology
already exists as part of the community
fabric it has for decades
we just unintentionally zoned out what
has worked for our communities
these four plexes are not a new and
mysterious idea they've been part of the
landscape for decades
but the procedural gymnastics required
to even propose housing that is denser
than a single family is preventative
we're asking to put a tool back in the
toolbox for housing development
not a mandate just a tool for
consideration a tool that was taken out
unintentionally decades ago that we need
back
i think these are a great addition as
someone said to our existing
communities where we need neighborhood
appropriate density and i think this is
a fantastic bill that representative
anne has advanced thank you
any questions from mr clement
yes
representative thank you mr chair thank
you mr clem for taking my question my
question is as a developer what kind of
clientele are approaching you to develop
such a unit is it just a
younger generation or people like me who
are looking towards aging in place
or is it mixed of both
multi-generational
both you know i
think of this type of housing as what
appeals to young couples starting out
and older couples downsizing
we see obviously with
dartmouth-hitchcock medical center and
the college
already a housing shortage and influx
certainly compounded by the past couple
years of the pandemic i think we were
one of the 10
largest net influx growth areas in the
country for the times
so i get people that are looking at
academia jobs looking at professional
jobs who are starting out and cannot
approach
a single family home that is
suddenly 400 500 000
but when they relocate to new hampshire
to enjoy
the quality of life that we all enjoy
here
they're not necessarily looking for that
four-story five-story
uh multi-family building that they could
live in elsewhere in the country they
want to live where the activity is where
the coffee shops are where the
neighborhoods are
uh but it's increasingly hard to do so
representative
i'm sorry
follow up
thank you mr
chair isn't isn't it true that in in the
college both dartmouth college and the
medical center
is providing incentive to the local
single-family residents to
single-family homeowners
to take in paying guests and the
university would pay for their housing
that they cannot provide on campus for
them
i can't speak to that specifically but i
know that with
hundreds of students being on campus
that were otherwise expecting to be off
campus that was prohibited due to covid
for travel abroad or what have you study
abroad
that we had 500 additional students
adding to our already very tight housing
market
i think the college and the hospital are
taking steps to take big bites out of
the problem by doing their own housing
but again this is just another tool
um and it's about people who can't find
that because they're competing with
students medical professionals etc we
need all types of housing to solve the
problem
thank you mr chair and thank you mr clem
for taking my question
i sit on the lebanon planning board as
you may know
and we um are under tremendous pressure
for the reasons that representative
manjuputi just mentioned
to um
to review and accept
proposals for
mega developments 200 400 500 unit
apartment buildings
do you think that if this bill were to
become law that it would relieve some of
that pressure
on planning boards such as in lebanon
where there is ample
infrastructure water public water and
sewer and there may be fewer of these
large developments that come before
planning boards and pose tremendous
problems for us and more
middle of the road housing
i do i mean i i think when we have
studies that show that our region is 10
um
units shy
all housing is needed and i think part
of the reason that lebanon is seeing so
many big projects is because there's not
an avenue right now for other types
so yes i believe that opening up this
typology that is not even on the table
right now for me to apply to the
planning board with creates a new avenue
for investment capital to come in to try
to solve the housing crisis so that you
can't just take little bites
one unit at a time often in subdivisions
in green
um greenfield development you can create
interesting downtown typologies around
our current two downtowns as we have in
lebanon
where you're not putting big buildings
up on hills in the middle of
untouched areas
thank you mr chair thank you mr clem
do you also think that it might
relieve some
pressure on our environment in new
hampshire
where some of these major developments
of 3 4 500 units
are near wetlands or on wetlands or
on on steep grades
where
building there really endangers the
environment and the wildlife do you
think that it could help preserve new
hampshire's rural character
absolutely and i speak as someone with
an environmental policy degree uh who
ended up in the development field
um i think we're talking about
development where development already
exists with this bill this is an infill
bill this is a downtown development bill
this is the surrounding circles of our
towns bill
so yes i believe it pulls development
back towards the city center where it
should be as opposed to continuing to
push it out to areas that could
otherwise be left for other uses to
enjoy the outdoor recreation for example
in new hampshire
next we're going to go to representative
rong and then representative
thank you mr church
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
clint for taking my question
um
as far as your industry goes if this
bill were to pass into law how would it
affect that industry would it create
like a niche area or would it be
absorbed with current developers
i think it opens a new niche for sure i
mean this is a
typology that i could walk into my local
bank and we could scratch out on the
desk in an afternoon as opposed to these
large-scale developments that have
enormous calls for capital large
permitting challenges etc this is
something that creates fast-track
housing growth which i think is
important i don't know who decides to
play in this space i don't think it
likely becomes attractive to the big
developers who are pushing for the
larger units
i think to representative van's point it
allows people like representative anne
to to turn their house and from over a
size into a four unit or propose smaller
stuff or take those contractors who have
the capabilities to build this and give
them something that
they with their small business can go
ahead and do profitably without seeing
nothing but red flags and obstructions
if they were to try to take this to the
planning board for example
so it would um i guess on turn it would
it would create a specialization among
developers and contractors
would you say
perhaps
i mean i i think it's
it's another possibility i don't know
that they would specialize solely in it
i think it's so specific to
who the what their skill set is what
their access to capital is i think when
you look at the conversation that's
happening around this nationwide and
we're seeing
uh
federally and financially approved
housing
that we just can't do here at the state
level
yes i think we're just missing
opportunities right now because we don't
have legislation like this to exist that
says hey here is a logical path to get
to housing that is time tested and
proven in the state of new hampshire
already
thank you
okay uh
mr clem um appreciate your testimony
and uh if you want to stay and hear the
others you're welcome absolutely thank
you sir thank you
did you have something you wanted to add
okay
uh
mr firth
before you get up i want to tell you
that
i understand you're from arlington
virginia
and we have some local residents that
want to speak so i'm going to let you
speak but i'm going to
bring up the local folks first
so next
representative rebecca mcwilliams
welcome
thank you so much chair it's a pleasure
to be here for the record my name is
representative rebecca mcwilliams i
represent the west side of concord so
the legislative office building is in
one of my districts it's a pleasure to
host you all in my district today
i'm here to speak about the younger
generation and i'm sure this is not news
to you
but as an architect actively working in
new hampshire
and often my clients are
in their 20s and 30s
looking to do a renovation project just
to give you a little bit of background
so as a younger person in new hampshire
i will tell you that there is a huge
amount of demand
for
housing that includes more than one
space and i will tell you that these
very popular three and four family even
duplexes in our downtowns in new
hampshire are the hottest commodity for
young folks to buy and renovate and then
live in one side rent out the other i
mean that is just the gold standard
that's what young people are looking to
do
generally when they get to new hampshire
and they decide they want to purchase
something hire an architect hire a
contractor renovate make it work
financially
so
what we have here is a lot of existing
wonderful buildings beautiful historic
downtowns the young people are coming in
and they're willing to spend the money
and renovate
but we also have these missing teeth in
our downtowns
we have empty lots
we have derelict buildings that really
should be torn down but if we were to
tear them down then we wouldn't be able
to build per zoning what was there
before unless it gets grandfathered on a
town-by-town basis
so what we're talking about with this
bill is actually revitalizing and coming
back to what worked for our zoning codes
pre-world war ii
and it worked well we had walkable
downtowns we still do but we also have
these missing teeth so this bill solves
a problem for the next generation for
what is really an opportunity a business
opportunity for an individual or a
couple to buy and make some money and
build a nest egg and maybe save for
their children's future and this is the
kind of housing that we really should be
looking at for the future of new
hampshire so with that i'm happy to take
questions anyone have a question for the
representative let's start with uh
representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
i'm going to go back to my experience on
the lebanon planning book for just a
moment
the very large developments that we're
seeing come before us
i would say eight times out of ten
are
conceptualized
developed and managed by companies that
are not in new hampshire
they're in massachusetts they're in
delaware they're in
other places
do you think
that if this bill became law
it would stimulate
new hampshire business
in other words local contractors local
developers
local plumbers local carpenters in ways
that these large buildings just cannot
do
that's a great question representative
let me parse that out a little bit
when we're talking about really large
developments
often times the money flows out of state
once it's completed so we are talking
about local jobs for a short period of
time one to two years
for getting through the permitting
process and for doing the construction
work
but oftentimes
especially if it's a local developer
they will bring in their own crew from
out of state so if you're seeing a lot
of massachusetts developers they may
have their own cast of characters that
are willing to drive up to new hampshire
to do the development for a year or two
so we do have local talent we have
excellent trades people here in new
hampshire and right now we're in a
building boom they're they're very busy
right now what this bill does is it
codifies into law and opportunity for
folks to help out on these very small
infield projects in perpetuity so there
will always be work for your local
trades people we instead of having these
you know 10-year building boom and then
10-year building bust which is generally
how the cycle goes we're talking about
always having an opportunity at small
scale to fill in and do a four or five
month carpentry project to do work here
locally in new hampshire and i think
that's huge in terms of supporting the
trades and i think that that's very
important for the long term because we
often lose really quality talented
people to go south to the boston market
right we have excellent plumbers and
excellent pipefitters and they end up
taking jobs elsewhere because there just
isn't enough chance here when the market
isn't hot like it is right now
thank you representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
would you um
being an architect would you believe
that this not only creates more job
not just job opportunities for local
talents to pull together but also this
is ownership is local right it's small
enough that young people can afford to
buy
and renovated so the
development as well as the investment
and the benefit stays within the state
would you believe that
i would i think this is reinventing the
american dream i think we're talking
about getting back to 2.5 kids a picket
fence and a dog and giving that
opportunity to the next generation here
in new hampshire i think it's that
important
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question representative van made a
comment that
this is
going to change
how housing is done by
removing from local control to state
control
do you believe that there is anything
that is preventing
cities towns and counties from changing
their zoning to permit that this on
their own
i do
i believe that cities towns and counties
have really stumbled over making massive
change on their own because they're
waiting to see what the joneses are
doing nearby
i think we've had tiny incremental
change in some more
open to change communities but at the
level that we need to make change in
order to house the next generation i
don't see an individual town stepping
forward and doing something as
brave as this
that was a great answer
but
i don't believe it
answers my question
my question was is there anything that
is preventing
uh say a state law
towns
cities or counties from changing or
zoning to accommodate this kind of idea
if you're asking structurally if there
is a state law that prevents cities and
towns from setting up their own zoning
is that is that the question am i not
understanding it
can the
town or city or county
implement this
density on their own
structurally there's nothing preventing
them structurally
politically all the time that's why
we're here in this situation it's been
40 years of no change
thank you
yes at this point uh
i want to thank you for your testimony
representative
and being patient with our schedule
next we'd like to hear from ms lilly
berger from portsmouth
yeah my name is lily beyer
i am in fact ivy's daughter um but i'm
here because
i am
uh interested in the built environment i
am a young person who is living in one
of these buildings i'm also a structural
engineer so that by trade i have some
interest in the built environment in
general this isn't something that's
probably going to affect my workforce
flow particularly we tend to work on
those big 200 unit projects
um however
this is where i live i live in
portsmouth um behind the ball field in a
neighborhood that's made up of
single-family duplex four plex we have a
couple of traditional boston triple
deckers we've got a couple of you know
small
duplexes
we have single family houses we have my
house which is a triple it's my landlady
lives on one side i live on the other
side i have a downstairs neighbor
so there's two tenants and the building
owner and
walking down richards avenue it's one of
the best streets in town
and
we can't
always build that and this is something
that a lot of places adding a couple of
units inside an existing structure no
one's gonna know walking down the street
you don't know you just see a place
that's vibrant
and has people outside walking their
dogs
and a place that people want to live
people like me we want to live stumbling
home from the bar distance we want to
live walk to the coffee shop and see my
friends distance we want to live in town
and
one of the problems is because so many
people want to live in town if we don't
do this kind of thing no change is not
an option what we get is increased
prices because people want to build that
to live there
and if we sit on our hands
and do nothing
everything gets more expensive and
people like me people like my friends
who want to live in town they can't
because they can't afford to
whereas if we allow and in fact
make it easier
for more units like the one i live in to
be built
that's how we make more space for the
people who want to be here
so saying well this is a big change
that's not really true because doing
nothing is a big change doing nothing
it's easy it feels safe but it doesn't
actually result in no change it results
in increased prices
lower supply as
people
can't
turn their large single family house
into a couple of units that could be
rented i'm a renter i've been a renter
in the same address for the last eight
years i'm a member of my community
saying renters don't really belong here
renters don't really participate that's
not true either we're here we matter
and we're part of the community and this
is the kind of place that we want to
live
we want to live within our community we
don't want to live in the big
multi-family 200 unit apartment
complexes we do because that's what's
there
but that's not what we really want
and this is a bill that allows the kind
of places that people want to be to
happen i work on those big buildings but
that's not where i live
and that's not where my people live
so this this is something that's super
important and it will allow the places
we love to continue to be the places we
love and not just
the people who have the money
we don't have a lot of money typically
in my generation we have a lot of
student loans so living someplace that's
smaller
that's where we want to be i live in a
building that has no parking it has
three four adults with cars not a single
parking space and it's okay we park on
the street when it snows we move to city
hall
or down the street there's a lot there
are ways for this to exist
without it being a problem
and that's what we want
i thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee
miss
thank you mr chair um thank you uh for
taking my question
if
you i mean when you moved in
did you choose this option because it
was available or
did you kind of find this opportunity to
move into a triplex uh and rent
uh i
looked at several places some were
further out of town some were more local
i chose it because
it's a great location
it's the kind of place i want to live
that's dense that's walkable that has
places to go within walking distance not
just the houses are close together but
there's you know coffee shops there's
downtown everything's right there so i
chose specifically to live in a place
and i couldn't afford to rent a whole
house nor would i want to i'm one person
with a dog like i don't need a big space
so this is the kind of place i want to
live in that has people around me
one quick follow-up is portsmouth the
livable walkable community or it's just
a compact
community that welcomes people like you
um
yes
it is a it is a livable walkable place
it's expensive which is one of the
reasons that this kind of bill would
improve things
is that it's relatively difficult to
make more of the portsmouth that we love
um so
the places
you have to get lucky to find a good
apartment there just because it is in so
high demand
representative cleve
uh thank you mr chair and
my apologies because i had hoped not to
ask a parking question and i'm going to
so i apologize for this
my question is
and before i ask it just to let you know
the community i live in
we don't allow overnight parking from
midnight until 6 pm without permit and
only in certain locations so my question
is the community you live in do they
allow overnight on street parking
um without any kind of other than snow
and i know that the foul weather type of
thing yeah absolutely i don't know why
you wouldn't i mean it's there's four i
think it's a we have 60 foot of frontage
or something like that which is for
parking spaces
and
i don't why would you take that curb
space away from the people who live in
that community i it baffles my mind and
we they don't even make you move off the
street unless there's significant stuff
and it works
again that's in your community of
portsmouth is that correct
um and may i have a just a quick uh
follow-up certain thank you so i'm going
to ask a question
um have you ever been to
areas of nashua such as the french hill
and everything where the very dense
community
without that same amount of frontage
and narrow streets
um i'm not familiar with the community
specifically
i think that answered the question that
you would ask them thank you
hey
thank you for your testimony appreciate
you welcome to stay
next representative tim horrigan
he's not here
mr will stewart
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is will
stewart and i'm the executive director
of stay work play new hampshire uh we
are a statewide nonprofit whose mission
is to attract and retain more young
people here in the granite state and we
are in support of this bill um
representative van and the previous
speakers have done an excellent job i
can't add much more to it but i do want
to add a little bit of emphasis
on the need to attract and retain more
young people and its relation to housing
both options and affordability you know
new hampshire as you may know is the
second oldest state in the country and
we have one of the lowest unemployment
rates pre-coveted now we're back at
pre-coped levels now at what 2.6 i
believe the data came out last week
so we need more people in general we
need more young people in particular not
just for our employers who are screaming
for employees across industries across
the state you know but our towns you
know who need volunteers to serve in
those planning board positions those
conservation commissions you know for
our non-profits who need people to serve
on their boards of directors and their
committees to do the work that we need
done in civil society here in new
hampshire you know and again for our
employers
the biggest barrier facing young people
and we know this at state work play
through both data and a number of
anecdotal conversations that we've had
in um
across the state you know in recent
years is housing it's it's housing
affordability as representative
gallagher noted with his brother having
to move out to oregon it's incredibly
difficult uh to find a
starter home either an apartment or
certainly a place to buy increasingly
increasingly difficult you know so for
that reason you know we need more
housing options we need to increase that
uh supply because this is a supply and
demand issue and it's being artificially
constrained right now you know let's let
uh your property owners you know have
more rights with their own property you
know to let the market
help alleviate this situation thank you
any questions from mr stewart
from the committee
yes representative
thank you mr chair um
thank you mr
stewart for taking my question
so you have been with the work play and
stay in new hampshire for a few years
yes ma'am and uh this was pre-covered
too correct absolutely okay so um you
hit the very key point on unemployment
how would not just the unemployment
and um
attracting more younger diverse
how would this also
in terms of attracting
diversity
of folks coming into the state
you know i think having more options you
know makes it a possibility for more
people of all backgrounds you know to be
able to move here and uh you know part
of the challenge right now you mentioned
you know employment and employers and
increasingly your housing is becoming an
employer concern you know it's something
that you know i've heard from employers
you know on the seacoast who in
portsmouth in particular you know in the
restaurant and other entertainment
industries also in the lakes region and
beyond you know who say that you know
they would you know they're screaming
for employees you know they can only pay
so much and that uh your their employers
your employees can't afford to live
anywhere near their place of business so
they're having to go farther and farther
out and um you know that's becoming
unsustainable for those employees you
know to be able to drive in and
especially when they can get you know
better wages closer to where they are
they're more likely to stay there so
it's it's a challenge all the way around
thank you
um just flipping that coin a little bit
work play stay
play and stay in new hampshire but you
could be working virtually elsewhere
would new hampshire become an attractive
destination for young folks to
live here play here but work remotely
god knows where but that would be that
would be another
source of economy
for entertainment and uh revenue for new
state of new hampshire wouldn't that be
correct yeah that's already the case
we're seeing it as a previous speaker
you know noted we are in the uh you know
one of the top 10 destinations during
covet and even pre-covered you know we
were new hampshire is one of only 10
states you know that's seeing an influx
of people in their 20s and 30s you know
a net in migration it's modest yo but
it's here and i think you know now that
uh you know these work from home
opportunities are certainly more
prevalent than before it's you know all
that much more likely and uh you know
i'll say with one thing it's
new hampshire is a super attractive
place for so many reasons you you
mentioned the playing and all the
outdoor recreational amenities that we
have here and those opportunities which
is a big reason that people want to be
here they want young people want to be
here
but they they find it very challenging
to do so and especially to to come in
with no uh you know family support or
anything like that i remember i
mentioned you know statewide going
around the state in recent years i
remember
we were up in lebanon and uh at the salt
hill pub you know talking to a group of
young people about what they like about
the upper valley and what might cause
them to leave and
one of the things this a young woman
said and she was speaking specifically
to the upper ballet but i think it
applies you kind of writ large to new
hampshire she said the upper valley is a
wonderful place to raise a family but it
can be a very difficult place to start
one and i think that's that's where we
are right now and you know where
solutions like this you know it's not a
silver bullet it's not going to solve
all the problems facing young people in
new hampshire not even all the housing
problems facing young people in new
hampshire but it is you know one piece
of the solution that i think could help
yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
stewart for your testimony
you mentioned that
businesses have developed a concern
about the limited housing for their
employees
and and that and that's a concern
are you aware of any businesses who have
made a decision to leave the state or
not come to the state because of the
housing crunch
you know it's hard to say that uh
businesses i don't have enough knowledge
to say businesses outside the state not
coming here you know but i can certainly
you know speak to you know some here
that are evaluating all of their options
you know from you know the the labor
supply being the biggest issue and
housing being i think one of the biggest
you know bigger if not the biggest
factor you know on the supply of labor
you know here in the state who are
looking at uh other places you know down
south out west that have you know lower
housing prices you know lower cost of
living and
you know that
they might not otherwise consider if
they didn't have to thank you
okay uh
thank you mr stewart i appreciate your
testimony and our penultimate speaker
will be
mr grays from the nhma
thank you mr chair h grace for the new
hampshire municipal association
uh
we have the distinction of opposing this
bill um it is a statewide zoning mandate
and we we oppose statewide zoning
mandates we support local control
options uh historically zoning ordinance
zoning ordinances have been determined
at the local level and tailored to the
specific community and we think that's
the appropriate way that they should
continue to be
um continue to be
created
um as far as this bill goes um there is
one thing that came to my attention this
morning
as the committee was was questioning
some of the speakers um and that is
i would caution the
committee to look at the accessory
dwelling unit statute
rsa 674 colon 72.
um in that there is a line that says the
municipality is not required to allow
more than one adu for any single family
dwelling
and that the municipality may prohibit
an adu with multiple single-family
dwellings
that
appears to contradict
the bill
in the line about how the
lines
six through eight
and how the
four unit
building
or
other division
um could be
arranged particularly with regard to the
one single family house with three
accessory dwelling units um so there's
some contradiction there that
may have to be resolved if this is
something that the committee wants to
go forward with
and of course there's also the the
second
part of the adu uh
set of statutes 674 colon 73
about detached adus
and that may of course impact how
such units may be configured as well
i i lastly want to mention that the
amendment um that was presented this
morning by representative vann
does address some of the concerns that
some of our members have raised with
regard to parking requirements i know
that was an issue that was brought up by
representative clee earlier
it it was an issue i i asked
representative van about last week
and it does clarify that
the
the number of parking units
corresponds to the number of dwelling
units
and it was ambiguous in the bill is
written as to how exactly that would
function
um so i thank her for clarifying that
i'm happy to answer any questions
any questions yes representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
grace for taking my question
uh your first comment in your testimony
was about the fact that this isn't
enabling legislation that it would be a
mandate
so and i know representative vann
referred to that as preemptive zoning
is the new hampshire municipal
association against all preemptive
legislation or do you find that there
may be situations where the state does
need to
mandate municipalities to
abide by the same rig the same
regulation
so our policies are adopted by our
members at our bi-annual conference and
one of the policies they've adopted is
to oppose statewide zoning mandates so
where that's the case we oppose those
there are
i guess cases where
things don't fall neatly into
into buckets like this one does is
clearly a zoning mandate in which case
we would go back and ask our board for
further guidance
okay thank you
any other further questions yes
representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr grace
for taking my question
to further expand on representative
rung's
chain of thought
new hampshire municipal association
opposes statewide
zoning ordinance or changes and
but what is the solution that new
hampshire municipal association would
offer or would be willing to work
in order to address the acute crisis
that we have for housing in our state
and
acute shortage of workforce and all that
you know is there a solution
i i don't have a solution if i did i
would certainly offer that to the
committee i'm certainly happy to work
with anyone on any bill they have
related to municipal matters including
zoning matters
certainly i see my role as being
informative as well as advocating for
our positions
thank you uh mr chairman and uh thank
you for taking my question
um
i i guess i'm looking for clarification
so
the the relative to opposing mandated
zoning is because each community is
different and unique
and therefore they would have to know
what was best for them and it would be
more difficult to just do an umbrella
type of law is that is that the stance
that you guys have taken yes and if i
could i use an example that you brought
up earlier you know it appears there's a
community in nashua where
there isn't sufficient street parking
for the number of uh dwelling units that
might be created
whereas portsmouth
it appears from the testimony received
by the committee earlier that that's not
the issue so you know there are
differences between communities i i
obviously
can't resolve all of those but that's
that's traditionally why zoning has been
determined at a uh at a local level and
why we think it is appropriate for it to
continue to remain that way
thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um in your testimony you referred to an
rsa
pertaining to adus could you repeat that
first reference yes that was our say 674
colon 72 um that's the
the first of two um adu statutes um and
it essentially what it does is it states
that
uh everywhere there's a single family
home
a municipality must allow
a
a single
adu
and then it goes on to state that a
municipality may prohibit more than one
adu
per
single-family dwelling and
they also prohibit adus where there are
multiple single-family dwellings on the
same lot like a townhouse um there's
actually a short
list of things there but the one i
remember is townhouse
so that may um or doesn't
have a have a
conflict with the bill as proposed
and our last speaker thank you
thank you
natchez a lot of speaker salem firth
who represents the mercado center
chairman dolan vice chairman pia monte
and members of the committee thank you
my name is saleem firth and i study land
use regulation and housing markets at
the mercatus center at george mason
university
mercatus is a non-profit nonpartisan
organization dedicated to
market-oriented solutions to policy
problems
it is a privilege to come before you
again and especially to be able to do so
this year in person
allowing more homes per lot as hb 1177
would do
would promote affordability conserve
municipal resources have less impact on
far forests and farmland and promote
property rights while leaving intact the
look and feel of neighborhoods
in my written testimony i discussed some
of the benefits of denser zoning and
other cities and states experiences with
similar policies
but i want to focus my remarks on the
real issue at stake here which is not
the the modest but positive effects this
bill is likely to have but whether the
state ought to decrease the regulatory
authority it has granted municipalities
as a new england native i am keenly
aware that our towns have been vital
institutions for centuries
but local powers have never been
boundless and have long been contested
and restrained
there are three arguments in favor of
preempting municipal zoning authority
number one property rights
those who propose to limit citizens
right to the normal use and enjoyment of
their property ought to face the burden
of proof
unless the legislature believes there's
a compelling reason
that four households should not reside
on a lot where one household can
reasonably reside it ought to limit
municipal authority to impose that
specific restriction
number two is fairness the state
legislature can balance narrow town
interests against the interests of
granite staters who live outside the
towns in question and do not have
representation
and three
solving statewide problems states can
preempt local government when necessary
to achieve a statewide goal for example
recent zoning preemptions have been
justified as necessary to address
climate change or to increase economic
growth
unlike in the case of property rights
here the burden of proof ought to be on
the state to show that preempting a
traditional domain of local government
is in fact necessary to address a
statewide problem
thus the debate is not about whether the
state should ever restrict local
authority it already does
using the framework i just gave the
question is whether in this particular
instance one
local regulators can make a compelling
case that maintaining single-family
zoning is sufficiently important to
merit restricting the use and enjoyment
of private property
and whether that case is outweighed by
two
other citizens interest in housing
availability or three statewide concerns
such as environmental protection housing
affordability and economic growth
thus the bill before you and others like
it are substantive not procedural
questions state legislatures should not
always preempt local authority nor
should they always defer
still in my view single-family zoning is
ripe for reconsideration
thank you for your time i'm happy to
answer any questions any of your
questions
representative
thank you mr ted thank you for taking my
question um you brought out the
rental property rights kind of thing
is
would this
uh bill enable
uh the renter's representation also in
the community by participating more
because they have the option to rent
yes so uh frequently small small
multi-family dwellings are owner
occupied and then you know one or two
other units are rented out so it
certainly can allow renters to have a
greater choice of neighborhoods as other
speakers have mentioned
okay
thank you for your testimony
representative fan
i just want to follow up on nate gray's
comment about the edus i'll put in an
amendment that takes that strikes the
adu really the goal there was just to
say it can be any kind it can be one
building two buildings three buildings
or four
as long as it conforms to the local
setbacks coverage parking etc so i'll
just strike the language about adus and
that'll fix it
be ready before we uh what are you
planning to execute
uh probably next week yeah i'll go do it
today and they'll do it for me right
away thanks okay thank you uh
at this point i'm going to
allow the committee to take a quick
break
i'd like to see you back here at
10 40. and then we'll we'll continue
with uh
with bill 1194 house bill 1194. thank
you
mr chairman yes
i just like to inform the rest of my
colleagues that our chairman was just
honored by the town of londonderry by
name by his being named
man of the year
do such privileges extend into this room
also or can we still treat him like one
of us
he does he doesn't have a crown does he
you
thank you mr chair um i am the prime
sponsor oh you are yes and i'm here
you certainly are
go right ahead
thank you mr chair and fellow committee
members as the prime sponsor i
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today house bill 1194
relative to the procedure for overriding
a local tax cap
for the record i am representative diane
power i represent the towns of brookline
in and mason in hillsborough county
district 26.
this bill requires a three-fifth
super-majority vote of a legislative
body to override a local tax cap
this bill is a constituent request
following the signing into law of a
similar bill for cities in 2021
senate bill 52
currently under chapter 32 municipal
budget law
any local political subdivision of the
state
whose legislative body raises and
appropriates funds through an annual
meeting may adopt a tax cap by a
three-fifth super-majority vote
under a tax cap the total proposed
spending of all warrant articles
presented by the governing body or
budget committee at the annual meeting
is limited by the tax cap
and the legislative body can override
the tax cap with a simple majority vote
the purpose of a tax cap is to ensure
fiscal responsibility and prudence in
spending
tax caps across the country commonly
require a super-majority vote to
override
the issue that this bill addresses is
under current statute a simple majority
can override the tax cap which was
instituted by a super majority
the solution that this bill provides is
simple and straightforward
requiring a three-fifth supermajority to
override the tax cap
ensures that any spending that exceeds
the tax cap is in fact warranted and is
supported by the legislative body of the
town or district
in addition the provisions of this bill
are similar to the provisions of sb 52
signed into law last year which requires
a super majority vote for city charter
exclusions and ordinances that have the
effect of a tax cap override
additionally the framework of this bill
stipulates that in the case of warrant
articles proposing bonds notes or other
other multi-year expenditures
only the first year estimated costs
shall be used in calculating
appropriations for the purpose of
overriding the tax cap
this bill outlines the procedures for
overriding the tax cap in a municipality
that has adopted the official ballot
form of meeting
and lastly this bill specifies the
procedure for overriding the tax cap for
school districts that have adopted the
sau
alternative budget process under rsa
194.
moreover to be clear this bill does not
limit the legislative body's authority
to either increase or decrease the
amount of any appropriations or the
total amount of all appropriations
this bill in fact
allows the legislative body to increase
the amount of any appropriation or the
total amount of all pre appropriations
by a super majority vote
as well as they can decrease the same by
the usual procedures applicable to
annual meetings
it is reasonable that any extraordinary
spending which which exceeds the tax cap
should have a higher standard to pass
moreover a three-fifth super-majority
vote is required for bonds and notes in
multi-layer year lease agreements
without an escape clause
because
of the extraordinary financial
commitment
the minority needs to have a say when
extraordinary spending is proposed
finally the current law specifies that
cities override tax caps by a
super-majority vote to consent to
extraordinary spending
thus it's logical that a super-majority
vote is needed to override a tax cap in
school districts towns and village
district districts
a common approach for all political
subdivisions in new hampshire
in conclusion
this bill establishes a three-fifth
super majority to override a local tax
cap
this bill allow aligns the vote
threshold to both adopt and override a
local tax cap
and this bill provides this flexibility
and spending while maintaining fiscal
responsibility to the taxpayers
thank you mr chair that concludes my
bill introduction i'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
for the record we had
people
indicate that they supported this bill
and 10
indicated they opposed the
bill it was are there any questions for
the representative
yes representative
thank you mr chair and and mine is just
a real quick question
um three-fifths majority is that of the
voters at the time or of all voters
within that
municipality
thank you for the question so the
three-fifth super-majority vote for
annual traditional town meetings yes
that would be three-fifths of the voters
present and voting
thank you
president
thank you mr chair thank you
representative powers for taking my
question
so how would this impact cities where
it's not town meeting
voting for
it won't affect the
cities
thank you for the question
representative if i understand your
question correctly
this bill pertains exclusively
to towns districts
which could be a school district or a
village district
last year in 2021 there was a analogous
bill senate bill 52 which pertained to
cities with municipal charters
follow-up
no two a question for you are you gonna
yeah
good man
yes representative go right ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
mine is gonna be a little bit obscure
but
we've heard from
several other uh bills that town's
laws should be um
not mandated but uh enabling
so why is it the ones that we've decided
should be enabling which is most of them
why does this one
propose to make it a statewide mandate
thank you representative for asking that
question that's that's an important
point
so this bill
currently under current statute
local tax caps are enabling
a town a district
can
choose to adopt
a local tax cap
by a three-fifth super-majority vote
it's enabling it goes on to the warrant
and the voters
choose to adopt it or not
what this legislation here
proposes to do is to
require
that the vote threshold
for overriding the tax cap obvious
obviously also be a three-fifths
majority so it's not
it's not new legislation
it's
it's aligning the standard
so that there's actual teeth in the tax
cap
yes go ahead thank you for the answer um
my follow-up is um
your response to representative klee
about um town manage uh town meetings
where
uh is it uh the vote of those present or
those who can vote what about sb2 towns
where
you'd have to have a separate
meeting to
vote on that question
thank you for that question
um the framework of this bill
does address
that scenario
so that is addressed
in lines eight section b of the um bill
language beginning on page on line 18.
so it
it does address
the traditional town meeting as well as
the official ballot form of meeting
as well as
school districts that have adopted the
alternative budgeting process
yes representative manchuri
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative taking my question i'm
looking to make sure i understand it
correctly under parent a
warrant articles of proposing bonds or
notes only the first year
shall be included so for instance my
town is proposing a bond a 30-year bond
first year's payment
200-plus thousand dollars second and
subsequent year's payments could be as
high as
400 000
so if three years from now there's going
to be a tax cap only the first year
payment would be the one that would be
applicable
that is correct for the current for the
current year at which the legislative
body
is
passing the warrant articles
yes that section a
stipulates that
for bonds notes and other multi-year
expenditures only the first year
of those
bonds notes or expenditures is
used in the calculation of the tax cap
thank you
is catherine heck in the audience
is it is there are there any further
comments
not not about uh to the representative
but i just wanted to go back to the
online support and uh for 1177 39 and
oppose 13 and this one
online it says 16 support and 13 oppose
which is not your number
thank you mister
yes representative ron thank you mr
chair and thank you representative power
for taking my question
um how many towns in new hampshire
currently have a tax cap and do you know
what that range would be
yes thank you for the question
representative so currently based on my
research
towns with tax caps there are four
and i could list them if you would like
allstate litchfield milton and newport
in school districts with tax caps there
are three
that is that they would be claremont
local brookline and newfound era
regional
follow up yes
and uh what what is the range of the cat
tax cap what percentage
thank you for that follow-up
so um
tax caps can be a fixed dollar amount or
a percentage i did not research
that
data point that you're asking but i do i
can share that in the brookline school
district our tax cap is eight percent
eight percent thank you and one more
follow-up mr chairman thank you
um
school districts in particular that's
what i'm familiar with they get a lot of
revenue that's not raised by by local
property tax they might get it from the
federal government they may get grants
whatever
um
is are those revenue sources
subject to the tax cap or is it only
that spending which israel is raised by
local property taxes
thank you for the question
representative so my understanding with
regard to municipal budget law
is that there is a max appropriation
per the tax cap and so that would be
calculated
in part where you would have to
calculate the maximum tax effort
and then you would have to include
appropriations
in order um
to
determine
the maximum appropriations per the tax
crap
cap
excuse me
easy for you to say
sorry thank you
representative stavis
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative i'm sorry having trouble
seeing you
for taking my question
you just you did some research and
counted up the number of towns
and cities in new hampshire currently
have cap tax caps and i was
astounded that there are so few
do you
do you have any sense of
why
if tax caps are such a great thing that
so few municipalities have adopted them
um i can and thank you for the question
representative
so with regard to that it would it would
be my opinion or supposition you know
obviously i have not done research to
you know query
the different uh towns and districts as
to why they do not have a tax cap but i
could
share with you
that
normally how
articles get on the warrant is through
the governing body
so
it would be up to the governing body and
in general governing bodies in my
opinion
you know
don't want you know aren't
probably interested in in tax caps they
just want to do and you know what they
want to do
and so therefore
tax caps would have to the other
alternative was to would be to put that
article enabling legislation on the
warrant by a petitioned warrant article
by citizens
i can
tell you that that is exactly how
the tax cap in the brookline school
district came to be it was through
petitioned warrant article
representative
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
on line 15 uh there's a phrase here that
says multi-year expenditures could you
uh elaborate a little on that
um a multi an example oh thank you for
the question representative an example
of a multi-year expenditure would be a
lease a lease agreement
in which there may or may not be an
escape clause
renting equipment
for example i'm aware
in in brookline school district that
there
is on the warrant a
multi-year expenditure in
for
a lease for hvac equipment if you can
believe that
thank you representative mancha
manchapudi
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking a another
question um just in terms of looking at
number
four towns three
saus
and totally how many towns and saus do
we have
in new hampshire what percent i mean
this is a small percentage of what we
have in new hampshire
to mandate that
from the state level don't you think
that is
um
a bit too
restrictive
or not quite enabling thank you for the
question representative so um
my recollection is that there are
approximately 246
municipalities in the state of new
hampshire i do not have the data point
um
with regard to how many school districts
there are
so therefore i you know i did not do the
type of calculation that that you're
asking me about
but you did
ask me if i feel that this is
restrictive i will reiterate that a tax
cap
is
enabling legislation
and the purpose of this
is to
give taxpayers
tools in their tool box
to
control spending and in short
this
super majority requirement to override a
tax cap puts teeth into the tax cap
because currently right now
you have the starting point
of the
total appropriations that are brought
forward to the legislative body by the
governing body or the budget committee
and
it can be
exceeded by a simple majority
representative gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
uh early or maybe just this last
sentence um
he stated that the governing body is the
one that
is out of is in control of whether or
not a town uh institutes a tax cap but
isn't it really the legislative body
that does this thank you thank you for
the question they vote on the question
they don't just say the governing body
can't say
we're doing a tax cap
they have to recommend for it to be put
on the warrant
thank you for the question
representative i'm not sure that i
understand the question as you um posed
it if i did mistake misspeak i apologize
clearly it's the legislative body that
votes to approve or
just deny
a local tax cap
it is not the governing body
what
my reference maybe perhaps to the
governing body was that the governing
body is what brings forward
you know the warrant articles and total
appropriations and in the case of a
school district in which there is an
official budget committee it would be
the budget committee who quote unquote
owns
the operating budget and it is not
brought forward or proposed by the
school
board gov which is the governing body in
that case
thank you
thank you representative power
i appreciate it appreciate your
testimony we're going to hear now from
catherine heck
from nhma
good morning good morning mr chairman
and committee members thank you
for allowing me to speak today
my name is catherine heck for the record
and i represent the new hampshire
municipal association and we are taking
a position of opposition to this bill
for the reasons that currently there are
in fact four municipalities that have
adopted a local tax cap provision and
the purpose of the tax cap is to limit
the budget authority of the elected
governing body whether it's the board of
selectmen or the budget committee
the tax cap
limits
the budget amount that they can bring
forward in the town meeting
however once the budget is presented the
town meeting is in the hands or the sb2
meeting is in the hands of the voter the
legislative body and they should be able
to make their own decision based on the
usual procedures of an annual meeting
which is through simple majority
this bill well it does still allow for a
majority to
override a tax cap it makes it more
difficult
we
our presumption is that
there was
a level of comfort or discomfort giving
the elected body
the provision to present whatever budget
it felt necessary and therefore in the
four cases that we can find a petition
warrant article was brought forth by the
voters to create a tax cap under that
provision in which the four towns
adopted the tax cap it was under that a
simple majority could then at the annual
meeting bring forward um an approp an
increase in appropriation and certainly
without a tax cap at any time the
legislative body can decrease
appropriations or change appropriations
on the floor of town meeting i did want
to briefly touch upon a question that
was asked by representative majori about
the first year of bonds notes or other
lease expenditures being included in
that calculation
and
well that is
exactly how the bill reads i think the
reason why tax cap becomes challenging
is because in subsequent years your tax
cap can
automatically be
at capacity before you've even gotten to
start your new budget process maybe it's
for raises inflation whatever reason or
projects because
once you've adopted a note
a bond or a multi-year contract that
gets absorbed into your operating budget
for subsequent years so depending on the
dollar amount and the thresholds of an
adopted tax cap we do find in other
parts of the country
challenges with the constraints that
that brings upon
the municipality or the local
district we're not here to discuss the
school side of it however
as the bill reads i am concerned that
the tax cap to be overridden at a
deliberative session in an sb2 town
the voters have the right to make
adjustments at that deliberative session
and that's the only time they can make
that adjustment and then on the ballot
when they go to vote
a month later it would require that
three-fifths majority to then pass
whatever it is um that they were doing
so
again i believe in practice the current
law
does
limit the power of the governing body to
bring forth a budget that that community
doesn't feel
is reasonable and that's why they've
adopted a tax cap however the
legislative body should have all the
authority granted in the town meeting of
doing its will
and i'll take any questions thank you
miss heck
yes sir representative matt jory
thank you mr chair and thank you
catherine for taking my question miss
heck excuse me taking my question so
if i understand my own thought process
and if i understand you correctly
is it true then that setting the default
budget which will contain the
obligations for long-term contractual
agreements the bond
collective bargaining agreements lease
payments
will create a could create an issue here
for that default budget
yes it is my opinion that as sometimes
you will see a default budget can be
greater than the proposed operating
budget for the reasons that you stated
because of legal obligations
so that again could automatically
override
the number and the tax cap based on
those obligations
thank you mr two thank you
miss hacks for taking my question i mean
i'm going to ask you the same question
in terms of only four towns have adopted
tax caps
and
in your membership
in your association membership how many
towns do you have would you be able to
answer that question
won't this be like a very small
percentage of the total number of towns
in our state
yes all the towns are currently members
of our organization and
it would only affect the four towns that
have currently adopted it under the
provisions that they adopted it under
so it is only four communities at this
time i'm not sure if there's any
petition warrant articles or warrant
articles
this season regarding a tax cap
mr chief quick follow-up
mr chef quick follow-up follow-up
yesterday um
can you give me the number of towns that
you have as a membership 234 234 out of
four have adopted
that's correct so
would you believe that this is
like
too small a percentage
to implement
uh overall
um
tax cap spending cap whatever you call
that
yes
okay thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh i'm gonna follow
up on uh representative majorie's first
question about the
uh limit of the first year's payment on
a bond is then limited throughout the
next budget season will that have an
effect on a municipality's bond rating
if they know that uh the tax cap can't
be overridden so we're limited in the
amount of money
uh or the tax cap may not be
limited and therefore we may not be able
to pay the amount of the bond that's due
that year i i would have to check with
moody's rating agency to see if that
would affect their bond rating okay
thank you you're welcome
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee uh thank you miss hack
thank you very much okay uh we're at a
point in the uh
on our schedule where
we're so far behind
we are
past
the time that we've noticed for all the
hearings we're going to have today so
that gives me the
the unusual freedom of of taking some of
these next
earrings out of water since uh
everyone's been noticed and given a
chance to be here
so uh if you remember we had
some bad weather last thursday that we
we concluded our hearings a little bit
early on house bill 1223 i recessed that
bill
with the intention of picking it up
today
so we'll take
house bill 1223
next
good morning the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman and good morning
committee members i'm representative
jeanine notter i'm serving my sixth term
for hillsboro 21 the town of merrimack
house bill
1223 relative to meeting attendance
requirements for elected members of
budget committee and school board i put
this bill in for my constituent scott
adler he's sitting next to me in the
interest of time i'm going to hand the
microphone right over to him and refer
all questions to him thank you
thank you and just for your edification
there
to representative knotter there is
there are clorox wipes if you feel like
you want to
sanitize your
microphone thank you mr chairman uh
thank you mr chairman and committee
members for the opportunity to speak
today
my name is scott adler
i live in merrimack
i ask for this bill for several reasons
as it stands right now
a
elected official member of the school
board school budget committee
can miss three out of every four
meetings
um excused of course by the by the uh
the chair
and then they can attend a meeting and
then they can miss three more meetings
if you take a a school budget committee
for example that operates primarily in a
very short window
they can essentially miss 75 percent of
the meetings and they're not really
representing
the the taxpayers the public the schools
or the students
secondary to that
these meetings are occurring
[Music]
when some of the members are living out
of town
so snowbirds if you will
the bulk of the meetings are occurring
again over the winter time
a member
can
attend remotely
but that presents multiple problems
technology has failed on multiple
occasions it takes time to connect
and often times meetings are delayed as
a result of of that
people
can't hear on both sides of the
of the connection some for the the
member some for the the public
and it also requires a roll call vote on
each and every item
for those reasons
i'm asking that
in-person attendance be required and
that
the member must attend
all of the meetings with the exception
of
two meetings per year or or 25
of such meetings annually so this
actually needs to be amended to
um state that they need to attend 75
percent of the meetings
or they can miss two whichever is um
whichever is less
so
i'll take any questions that you might
have does the committee have questions
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um if i
was elected to a school board and
subsequently found that i have a
condition like i do which is epilepsy
well controlled but i have breakthroughs
and if i under unscheduled so if i have
more than two episodes of of
seizures that i cannot control i cannot
control when they are
missing two meetings may happen
because of that
and so am i being discriminated against
because i have an illness that i cannot
control
that is an excellent question and thank
you for that
the provision for extenuating
circumstances would be in there so in
that particular case that should be an
excused absence what this is really
targeting is those that may take a
position within the the community and
then they never show up to the meetings
that's a disadvantage to everybody that
they represent
are there other questions here
representative
thank you mr chairman and um
i know i have a head in my way so i'm
sorry i apologize
yes yours
could you please remove your head
representative tripp yes
um thank you so much for taking my
question and and it follows on uh
representative gilman
perhaps i i just missed it i i missed
the language of um
allowing for an excused absence and and
i'll give you an example if i if i may
um
i'm on the board of aldermen in in
national new hampshire
we do not allow more than two unexcused
absences or even excuse absences within
a quarter
if we do the
the board has to vote as to whether or
not you get your stipend you would not
be removed but something such as that so
are you saying that if in the case of
representative gilman where she'd had an
illness
and they excused her because of the
illness this would not apply to her
that is correct she would be excused and
therefore not this law would not be
applicable because it's an extenuating
circumstance
may i just follow up real quickly does
does that body vote on whether or not
it's an extenuating circumstance or is
it by the the chair that decides that i
believe the chair should hold that uh
position to be able to do that and just
a quick clarification follow up and
maybe this is for representative notter
is that in in the um
in the documentation in the in this
particular law
okay
so uh
please can you restate your question for
me uh
what you you had said yes that you felt
that you said you felt it should be the
chair that would make that decision and
i'm asking is that clear in this
particular law in the um
i believe that's an amendment that would
be required okay thank you so much
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so currently under
rsa 32 colon 15 section 6
pertaining to budget committees it
states that a member
shall cease to hold office immediately
upon missing four consecutive scheduled
meetings without excuse
do you
do you see or feel that this
bill may be in conflict with that
section of statute
i believe that that is uh the what needs
to be amended and and states that that
the problem that that is as is in 3215
is the word consecutive
so if again you can miss three and then
show up to one and miss three and show
up to one
so again it may need to have some legal
amendment on this i don't know
but
that's what needs to change
representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you sir for
taking my question
are you aware of how many incidences of
showing up in a meeting and then missing
three consecutive meetings and showing
up at a meeting have happened in the
last
period of time
sufficient to spur the development of
this piece of legislation is are we
talking huge numbers of people and
school boards across the state who do
this on a routine basis or how many
people are we talking about here
very good question and thank you for
that i can't state across the state what
the number of instances i can only go by
personal experience and i can say that i
i have seen it occur within my own town
where there are members that continually
get either excused absences
or they will show up for just every so
often just to keep their seat and again
really that's it's not fair to the to
the taxpayers
follow up mr chair yes go ahead
so typically in our committee we we tend
to
see a lot of enabling legislation
rather than statewide mandates and given
your testimony that this is something
you've seen happen in your town but
you're not aware of other instances in
the state do you think that applying a
statewide mandate for a problem that
exists by your own testimony in your
town is appropriate
i absolutely do just because i don't
know if it's occurred elsewhere i'm
pretty confident it does although there
is no absolute fact of that the reality
is is that all of these school board
school budget committees etc all operate
under 3215 they're all governed by the
exact same rsa which says they can miss
four consecutive meetings
and then
three meetings and then they can attend
another one
and still keep their seat
again if you only have eight meetings a
year
think about that eight meetings a year
for a school budget committee
and you can miss
six of them
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i i think i'm piling on i just can't i i
just can't reconcile it in my head so
forgive me for this but
9283 says that
it says that
if you cannot attend by
in person
if it's not reasonably practical
but then this is a limiting clause on
that which which says that end
i'm just actually my question is is this
then a qualifying clause which says
i'm saying it's not reason to be
practical
and the budget committee has to agree
with that
is that what this does because i'm
trying to reconcile where 9283
and now
32 5 are going to work together
i i guess i'm not following your your
exact question there i'm not either okay
great
so
mr chair may i try to restate that yes
go ahead thank you so in 1923 it says
that remember the public may participate
in meeting other by attendance a person
uh only when such attendance is not
reasonably practical and that's stated
in here
but it says then only
if the budget committee finds
extenuating circumstances so i am
declaring as as one of the
representatives say
here says that i have a reason that is
that i have a stated reason which means
i can't be there
does this also say that you have to
agree with that
man
and therefore the last piece of that
does this create some conflict with 90
with 91a that's what i just want to make
sure i understand so is it is it 91a or
92a well 91 is what i should have said
and if i said 92 ipods okay so can you
read the first line of 91a again where
it said if a member
91a
hold on
91a colon 2 roman 3
parent a
a member of the public body which is a
member of the public body may
participate in a meeting other than by
attendance in person
at the location of the meeting only when
such attendance is not reasonably
practical
it continues on for a sentence that says
any reason that such attendance is not
reasonably
practical
shall be stated in the minutes of the
meeting
period
perfect thank you for clarifying that i
know that was going back and forth it's
okay
so
um
reasonably practical if a member
of the board lives out of town
to me that's an option for the member of
that board to do that but they shouldn't
hold office when the majority of the
meetings are going on
so
as an example
if there's eight meetings a year of
which six of them are held during the
winter period
then
that person should be expected to be in
person
live in in right there with everybody
else
because if they're not
ultimately what's going to happen is
you're going to have technology problems
you're going to have hearing problems
there's just it's it's it's a challenge
now
reasonably
practical if a member is ill and cannot
attend then they should be allowed to
attend via remote if it's a one-off
situation not an every single meeting
occurrence
i hope that answers your question thank
you representative
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
i don't this is this is so funny because
usually i don't ask my questions in this
direction but can you change your bylaws
of whatever the board is that is having
this issue
such that it says you have to attend you
know all the one of the meetings or
whatever your group of people says
rather than seeking a statewide
repair
excellent question thank you so
in in merrimack we do not have bylaws
for school budget committee
so they only govern they only operate
under 3215 and any other rsa that
governs them
yes
[Music]
so is there anything prohibiting them
from adopting bylaws
can't answer that question
because that seems like the easiest fix
representative
thank you mr thank you for taking my
question um part of the question i got
the answer from representative wien's
questioning my second part was
you know if we have learned anything
from the pandemic that we are
experiencing the year three
and you know
this was the only way the
electronic or hybrid was the only way
that i could participate
last year
in
the elected position that i have
and
so
you know
being new hampshire it's live free or
die everything is a voluntary thing are
we going to
shut people off because
they are unable to fulfill
the service
because of the illness because of any
extraneous
and you know you cannot participate in
the democratic parties
so uh have you considered that angle
absolutely and thank you for that so um
if the meeting is offered in what i
would call a hybrid model uh virtual and
in person by all means
then then this is not applicable because
it's being offered that way however if
you are again
missing meetings on a regular basis or
if you're
living out of town
during the bulk of of what's occurring
then that's a choice it's a choice to go
ahead and not be present but to to phone
in you're not seeing powerpoint
presentations you're not you're you're
not able to
directly engage with somebody face to
face in the meetings because you choose
to live out of town for an elected
position
uh thank you um
i'm not just talking about the phone
what the pandemic has status is a
video that we very successfully
participated and even this committee met
virtually in a hybrid
and i was able to participate exclu
because of my health condition i
couldn't be here
so it would if this was in place
it would have precluded me from
participating and fulfilling my duty as
an elected sure and i would not oppose
an amendment to show that if the meeting
is being offered in a hybrid manner by
all means i mean there may be times that
it's just more convenient to do so but
at least everybody's engaged all
together
versus one person living in another
state
trying to fulfill their duties here
representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
bringing this problem forward and i i
know that it hell enhance it does
happen and i don't know if you have a
particular situation with this out of
town
official but as a practical matter my
experience is that most committees
whether it be budget committee or school
committee or selectmen if they have a
member that's abusing their membership
the other members of that that committee
asked that person to resign
and it's a request it seems that this
puts some muscle into that where the
school committee does not or the uh the
budget committee does not have to
request they can demand that the person
leave is to add your understanding of
the intent of this bill
could i ask you to see if you could
format that type of question is that is
the intent of the
uh the bill to put some strength in the
ability of the other members of the
budget committee and the school
committee to ask the person to leave not
to resign but they can just they can
tell them to leave yes so that it would
provide a mechanism of removal as
necessary yes thank you
thank you representative representative
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
would you believe
that uh
do you like that
that
i
don't believe there's any
vehicle currently
in the uh state law that allows you to
remove a person an elected official so
this is a
a new instance of law correct there are
no mechanisms within rsa that allows you
to remove an elected official
that i'm aware of thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
adler and representative nodder for
accepting my question
um you testified earlier that this bill
came about because of a member of the
merrimack school district budget
committee
being away for the winter is that
correct
that is one of the reasons for the bill
yes okay and follow yes thank you and uh
you also brought up the
the whole concept that it was this
person's choice
i'm assuming that the voters made the
choice to elect this person
is that true and if so how many terms
how many times has this person been
elected to the school district budget
committee i can't answer how many times
they've been elected but yes she was
elected
okay thank
you yes uh representative tripp
you all set out
representative stavis
thank you for taking my question
um
i'm trying to ask this without being
flip
but i may not succeed
so please bear with me
do you think there's a reason why
there is no
uh procedure outlined in the state's
laws for remote removing and a duly
elected official that there's a reason
for that
that perhaps
the proper people to remove an elected
official are the people who elected that
official in the first place
let me let me follow that with a
different kind of question
how
how do those people that elected that
person remove that person
i respond mr chair
by not re-electing them
so
a person who's elected for a term of
three years can abuse the system
show up for
one meeting every so often just to keep
their seat and there's no way to prevent
that from occurring
until
that three-year term when they can be
voted out that's correct yeah
i i personally think that that's a flaw
in the system but i'm not a legislator
yes sir representative gallagher
so
um
oh so the legislation says
it would create a vacancy in the
election elected position
um so when is filled again
um would the person who
was removed under this law
would they then be ineligible for
running for the new election to fill the
seat or could they just run for it again
i would see no reason why they couldn't
run for it again it's not so then what's
your follow-up
so then
what's the point like if
if they can just run again and just get
reelected again then basically haven't
you just
basically made the town hold a pointless
election that just cost them money and
doesn't actually determine anything
well i wouldn't call it a pointless
election when they have elections
annually to begin with
secondly uh it would bring awareness to
the situation because others would be
aware of it
third and final it would allow somebody
to be in the position that could
contribute and represent taxpayers
students
personnel etc
during that period of time
okay thank you
okay
seeing no further questions from the
committee
we're going to close the hearing
oh i'm sorry uh
we have representative graves from uh
not representative but we have mr graves
from the nhma would like to comment
thank you mr chair and h grace the new
hampshire municipal association i hope
that i put a pink card in
we uh we oppose we oppose this bill um
obviously i only speak to the municipal
side of things
uh which would be uh lines three through
nine we don't repres i don't represent
the school boards
there are a couple items that i would
like to point out
first i agree with representative power
that lines six through nine which is
the second section of that new paragraph
that we added to the budget committee
statute
does conflict with rsa 32 colon 15 roman
6.
it would be unclear
which one of those would control
that currently provides that
that a member who
would cease to hold office immediately
upon missing four consecutive scheduled
or announced meetings
which uh
he or she had received reasonable notice
of and had not been excused by the chair
there was some mention from the previous
speaker about
a person serving who wasn't domiciled in
the town i just want to make sure the
committee is aware that rsa 32 colon 15
roman 5 exists
and that requires that every member of
the
budget committee be a member of where
that budget committee serves
so i'm unclear exactly what happened
there but if they're not living in that
district they would immediately cease to
be a member of the budget committee
excuse me when you say the budget
committee members have to be a member of
where that committee serves i mean they
have to be a resident of the community
correct
it specifically says domiciled in the
town or district
and that they would cease to hold office
immediately upon
moving essentially
and
i i would also
point out that this does add some
confusion with regard to how it would
operate with regard to the right to no
law rsa 9182 roman 3
because under that presumably what
boards do is they adopt rules of
procedure that determine whether or not
a member can
call in or otherwise participate
remotely
and this would seem to add an additional
requirement specific to budget
committees
that
that determination is
not just made by the member calling in
after
the board adopts such a rule of
procedure
but that
the whole board would apparently have to
then vote to determine whether
extenuating circumstances exist in this
particular circumstance so
to representative gilman's point if she
were trying to participate in a remote
uh remotely presumably the whole board
would have to vote
and presumably you know her medical
condition would be something they would
debate in public which
we generally discourage
i'm happy to answer any questions the
committee questions yes representative
guthrie
thank you mr chairman i have a quick
question i think it's my understanding
that what's going on now regardless of
what the rsa says
is that most
committees have a policy
that
if a person doesn't attend
a sufficient number of meetings
uh for
no reason that they are requested to
resign
isn't that the system that's being used
throughout the state in fact
i believe that a number of committees do
have a policy that they would after a
certain number of absences request the
member resign of course they're only
allowed to do what the legislature
allows so they wouldn't be able to force
that except in the case of
someone missing four consecutive
meetings
follow up mr chairman just quickly uh
can you
is it fair to say that the control
of a person being asked or a person
leaving is in the hands of the other
members of the
uh the committee
i'm not sure i understand it's still in
the hands of the committee they
determine whether the
absence is legitimate
whether or not there are none other
enough of them and then the the
committee does in fact is the one that
asks the person to resign
yes i assume that the committee would
look at the number of absences determine
whether they seem appropriate and then
determine whether they should request
that person to resign or not all right
thank you thank you mr chairman
on this bill we had
by the way we had two people
logged in to support it and two
logged in to oppose it
for a total of four yes representative
uh
gilman uh yeah that number has changed
since we started the hearing oh we did
it yeah uh it is uh support five of uh
pose 11. okay thanks for the update
yes representative
um
thank you mr chair thank you uh mr griez
for taking my question
would this
um
issue of trying to
bring the elected duly elected
public official to
participate
would would that
change with just the bylaw for the local
level so the local control if the voters
local voters elected
and put them in the office
and the board is
if they have a bylaw to request or make
that person
participate more consistently would that
solve the problem
i think that would that would address
the issue as representative guthrie had
mentioned earlier
certainly boards are free to adopt
you know
a process whereby they'd say you know if
you miss two or three meetings you
haven't told the chair what's going on
we're going to request that you resign
and then obviously state law kicks in
after missing four meetings so i think
it's something that could be addressed
at the board level
follow-up quicker
yeah so this
is that one of the reasons that uh nhma
opposes because it's a statewide mandate
versus giving the local control
yes
okay
seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you
at this point i'm going to uh recess the
hearing
on hb 1223 and open the hearing on hb
1259 and see if we can squeeze it in
before lunch if not we'll take a recess
to break for lunch
representative nada floor is yours thank
you mr chairman and hello again
committee members i'm for the record i'm
representative janine notter from
merrimack the town of merrimack
hillsborough 21.
house bill 1259 relative to the election
and resignation of members of school
boards and elected budget committees
again i put this in for my constituent
mr scott adler who's sitting next to me
and in the interest of time i will refer
all questions to him thank you
thank you mr chairman and committee
members my name is scott adler from
merrimack new hampshire
i asked for this bill
simply because there have been
years of stacking the deck within
school boards school budget committees
and what i mean by that is
agreements have been made for
resignations of members to occur after
an election period to allow the school
board school budget committee
to
appoint who they wanted instead of the
taxpayers being allowed to choose who
they want
the taxpayers are the ones in charge and
should be the ones that are represented
the taxpayers needs and desires
are not being met that way i think it's
providing a a bad look
to
any sort of
board or budget committee to to do
something like that
are there any questions please
okay uh representative klee
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
this is something that we used to do at
the beginning of our country with our
vice president became the um the number
two vote getter um and and i can see
the points that you make and and it's
shameful if that is that that is what's
happening here in in our state but my
question to you would be
um
if the voters had the option so in other
words the person who won wasn't on the
ballot
might not the um the voters have voted
more for three or four or five
um
elected official and in the case where
there's only two on the ballot uh might
the um things had changed differently in
a primary um which again is is something
that i want to uh
just a question if you haven't had an
information on that thank you
thank you let me let me restate what i'm
hearing you say so if there are only two
candidates
then one is elected
and then the other one who
did not win the
race now is is is put in as a result of
that resignation have i given that any
consideration is that what you're asking
yes
i
yeah that was the the premise of it but
the question is if the if that were the
only case there's only two
obviously that would have been
it's logical just put that person in but
what if there are three four or five
candidates or if there had been a
primary etc so thank you so so next
highest vote getter if it's within 90
days of the election the next highest
vote getter should be the one that's
given the appointment
may it clarify
thank you i i guess i'm i'm not making
myself clear
the point i'm making is that
um you want to put the second highest
vote getter or the the next highest vote
getter in from the person who who won
but if the because you said that that's
the voter speaking
but if that person had not run
would that person still maybe be the
second highest vote getter because
somebody else would have
exceeded that
i think that's why they kind of changed
the whole so winner versus loser kind of
thing the the second person may not have
gotten as many votes if there was
somebody else running right i i yeah i
understand the question and i i believe
that they should still be appointed
fair enough thank you
any further questions
yes representative guthrie thank you for
bringing this forward
the next highest
i i would say that it would be until the
uh the next election
to give the the voters a chance to
to go back at it
go ahead
is there another rsa that would would
cover i don't know if there is one
uh to cover
i know what the intent is and that is
what what the actually happens you stay
on until you know you gotta run in like
so but
would you believe that it's not clear to
me as to whether or not the term
only extends to the next election i i
believe that there is an rsa uh don't
don't quote me on which one but i
believe that there is an rsa that says
that if you're appointed you only serve
until the next election
if that's the case i feel comfortable in
but it wasn't clear to me thank you
thank you thank you mr chairman
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so my question
pertains to the use of
resigns in the words resigns and
resignation throughout the
bill
framework here
when i was a chair when i was the chair
of a budget committee
unfortunately one of our budget
committee members
died
while
holding that position does this bill
take into account account a death
the bill as written right now does not
mention that and i would
i would request that that be amended in
there because a
death is is similar to that
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i
hope i make this a little more clear but
i can never be sure
with reference to the
to the new bold provided
shall accept the resignation
and declare the vacancy within 10 days
so my question is a matter of timing to
you
and
we they have a monthly
a monthly meeting cycle why does it have
to be within 10 days could it could it
be could this be amended to say at the
next regular
meeting or is there some
reason for the 10 days in there that i
don't understand
it can be amended for the next regular
meeting
power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um
my question
here pertains to line 11
where the word beginning was struck and
the word end was amended in
why was that change made and
would this be problematic because
by eliminating beginning in in putting
end in there
of the filing period does that leave
a gap
so that's a great question and thank you
for that
as it stands right now the minute the
filing period opens anybody who resigns
or or
as a result of death that seat is now
vacant and cannot be filled via election
it can only be filled via appointment if
that is changed to the end of the filing
period it will allow another seat to be
opened up for the taxpayers to vote on
any other questions yes representative
ron
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
eller for taking my questions
i'm
just a little bit concerned that um
well well two things one you mentioned
that
this has been a major problem in
merrimack correct correct um i don't
know i don't know if i used the word
major but maybe i did but yes go ahead i
think you did um or something
similar
i live in merrimack and i think i only
know of one occurrence in the past maybe
six or seven years do you know more yeah
that's that's unfortunate the school
board as a matter of fact there's only
been one elected member of the school
board actually two as of this past year
uh going back uh that weren't prior
appointed members going back six eight
years now
it's it's it's a very unfortunate
situation the school budget committee
operating the exact same way where a
resignation would take place and there
would be what i would call stacking the
deck
so
in fact you could take a look at of the
school board in merrimack
you could go back at least three members
and see that
they were appointed prior to winning an
election
so yeah it has been a significant
challenge i'll have to check that's not
my recollection followed yes yes thank
you
um
in in in this
in this bill you're proposing that
people assume an office
that they were not elected to
or not appointed by someone who was
elected just the fact that they came in
second correct
what i'm asking is that the board
appoint
the next highest vote getter so that
would be
that would be the the board making that
vote okay but they don't have the choice
they have to take that step within 90
days is correct okay
follow up one more photo
i don't know if you're aware but i think
there was an instance in 2018
where that occurred but the next voter
the next person on the list was donald
trump he got five
write-in votes
the secretary of state
declared him ineligible because
merrimack was not his domicile and then
the next person who got three votes
actually didn't want the position he
didn't run a write-in campaign so i'm
wondering in that situation
if there wasn't anyone on the ballot
that had filed
are you proposing that the
board would then be forced to take the
next write-in voter
i wouldn't say somebody who's a write-in
i would say somebody who's actually
gone out and campaigned and and actually
filed and followed the normal steps uh
anybody can write anybody in as you just
uh as you just described so it would be
somebody who has actually filed and and
ran a campaign however
you you bring up another kind of
question in my mind and that is what if
nobody what if nobody's there what if
it's an unopposed race right then of
course you're back to appointment
situation so
um
i hope that answers your question uh yep
thank you
it was sort of i i guess my concern is
we have a history in new hampshire
a proud history of having elected people
have their m have made make the decision
on who's going to a point in those
situations
um and they're not forced to say you
have to have this person it's they still
have
the uh free choice to determine who they
want to appoint and they've been elected
by people
um
so
i guess uh
pertaining to the write-in if you're
going to draft a new amendment you may
want to clarify that because it's not
specific in your language
thank you thank you
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question
i'm totally confused it almost seems
like you're trying to create an
alternative to
duly electing process or democratic
process of electing your representation
either be it on school board or school
committee
and you know
taking that
away from the voter for the
representation
and you know
isn't the voters have the right to do
that and if you know and if they chose
elected somebody for three year term and
the person is not doing
in but
the voters have the ability
to vote them out or it just feels like
there's a alternative universe being
created am i
not seeing the point
so
right now
the
appointment is taking it out of the
hands of the voters
so
if somebody resigned because they held
their resignation until the elections
were completed
now that creates a vacancy
which in turn will cause an appointment
by the board that the taxpayers don't
get an opportunity to have a say-so in
so
if you go back to
who all was running and if there is a
second highest vote getter then instead
of it stacking the deck against the the
taxpayers or getting in you know
somebody's best friend if you will now
you've got a situation where the school
board school budget committees know okay
this is the next person i i that we have
to choose if it's within 90 days however
that being said maybe in the intent of
this is that it will cause people to
resign when the time is to resign
instead of holding it and being
strategic about
being able to appoint somebody
hopefully that answers your question
doesn't clarify thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um my question
is with regard to the the second highest
vote getter in in the election
um
have you addressed um
if that person is not interested in in
accepting that position
after the after the election yeah i mean
obviously that would have to be asked of
the uh of the recipient of the votes
whether or not they would still be
interested uh in attending uh or being
appointed at that point uh i don't
believe it specifies that in here um if
there's multiple candidates then
you know
and they're not interested then it would
have to go to an appointment situation
representative
um thank you again um and thank you
again for taking my question again i'm
going to go back down to the um the 90
days
um i understood what you said and and i
did find it disturbing the um someone
taking a seat just so that they could
resign and a favorite son or daughter be
put into into place but my question is
why wouldn't they wait 91 days
before they resigned and they very well
may
absolutely that is unfortunately there's
there's ways to you know game the system
any either way you go
you know just trying to trying to make
this a little bit more fair as best as
possible to stop the stacking of the
decks but absolutely it could however
let's say that a member is going to be
moving out of town and maybe they hold
off just long enough maybe they can't do
maybe they can't wait 90 more days
so
um
father what
mr chan go ahead um i understand what
what you're saying
but then if that be the case would they
not not have run they might have tried
to run somebody else
in that situation
can thinking that parties are running
people
i don't think i'm following your
question i'm sorry
um you you said that um
the possibility that um someone might
not be able to wait the 90 days
but if they ran with the intent
that they were going to give their seat
up to somebody else that could be
appointed um i i felt that that's what
you were kind of trying to say
no not they're not running with an
intent to give a seat up they're they're
on the the board or committee now
and their term is not up for re-election
but yet they resign shortly after the
election
so that
uh in a strategic way so that uh
the board can appoint a preferred person
in their place
rather than have the taxpayers vote on
it
thank you for that clarification
yes representative majori thank you mr
chair thank you for taking another
question my question is the last
sentence of roman
3 sub a this is for the budget committee
and it says if a seat on the budget
committee becomes vacant during the
filing period
the replacement for such vacancy shall
be added to the ballot
so it's the filing period and then what
has to happen
am i do i understand correctly that
during that filing period then the
budget committee is going to appoint a
person to run for that seat rather than
have somebody
volunteer to run for that seat if during
that one week filing period
that that person
that that becomes vacant do i understand
that
so my interpretation of this and and the
spirit of which it it should occur is
that if a vacancy occurs during the
filing period
then that
vacancy will be added to the ballot
so that the taxpayers can fill that
vacancy versus
an appointment by the board
i have a quick
i don't do that very often
so again and it could be me being wrong
which is most often the case the filing
period that that that you know
six seven eight nine ten days whatever
the number is
i signed up oops
i crossed my name out
are you saying that there's there's some
provision in there other than somebody
else signing up in there that i may
maybe i'm i'm getting so deep in the
weeds that i'm it's not relative we
might be talking about two separate
things i'm talking about an existing
member of budget committee school board
right that resigns during the filing
period
resigns during the firefight correct so
they already hold office they resign
during the filing period allow the
taxpayers
the voters to to vote in
versus because there's still an
opportunity to add that name to the
ballot
ballots haven't been printed the filing
period is still open
uh
add that person to the ballot so that
the taxpayers have to say so and what
occurs
yes sir representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
it's a follow-up to my previous question
i was trying to formulate
what i wanted to ask so it
we'll let's go back to line 17
with regard to the second highest number
so if i understood your explanation
um the person with the second highest
number of votes would be offered
the pos the the the seat on the board
and if they for whatever reason decided
or rejected that opportunity
then it would go to an appointment so my
question is
why is that the methodology and and why
not change second to next highest why
not exhaust
the list of
people who filed in ran
it just seems like it's disjointed
that is a
an excellent point that you bring up and
and i would be in support of that of of
exhausting that list
rather than uh just going with with one
person i think that would actually bring
some additional fairness to it
yes representative stavis
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking in another question which may
again be flip
that's why i apologize
so in in the first instance
where
a vacancy becomes
open because somebody resigned during
the filing period
this bill states that the participation
of the tax payers by an election is
paramount is important should be done
but then in the next paragraph it says
it's okay to appoint someone
i i don't i don't understand this bill
seems to want it both ways
the the the spirit of the bill
is
pretty simple to me but i'm not in the
the legal side of things it's
if a position comes open during the
filing period you allow the taxpayers to
vote on who that's going to be so you
add that name to the ballot
is that does that answer your question
taxpayers are
not allowed to vote
they have the right to vote
i i think we may be in semantics how
about we call them the voters
correct same same point okay so they get
to vote if it's on the ballot they can
choose whether to vote for that person
they don't get to vote in the second
instance in the second paragraph
they they voted prior to that
during the election they voted for who
they wanted and however many seats were
open if that person if their main vote
getter the the person who won the vote
or that the highest number of vote
getters were not
uh
chose not to accept the office then
um
or chose not to run i mean then they
would be
more than likely the winning vote
getter so they would be in automatically
well we can agree to disagree on that
but okay thank you for answering the
question
representative
thank you and thank you again for taking
my question so in that same vein the
replacement shall be added
that makes an assumption that does that
make an assumption that the replacement
must run
or could that word shall be changed to
may because this says the replacement
shall be added to the ballot
but i have not assumed that that
replacement wants to run
well if there's nobody you run then
there's nobody to add
so what that's saying is is if there's
somebody that's wanting to run you have
to accept
their application obviously with meeting
all the criteria
until the end of the filing period
so basically if there's four spots open
and somebody passes away or resigns it
now leaves a fifth spot open that's all
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question i want to follow up
on representative majori's point on
lines eight and nine if a seat on the
budget committee becomes vacant during
the filing period for a budget committee
election
the replacement of such vacancy shall be
added to the ballot for budget committee
election
are you aware that
for all other seats in school districts
or towns
this would conflict with that
i i'm wondering why you picked out
budget committee but didn't include
school board or town
board of selectmen or town council
because in in current rsas
if there is a vacancy that occurs during
the filing period
following that election
the governing board appoints someone to
fill that term until the next election
where then the unexpired term
is on the ballot
why would this
be something special and not apply to
all of those other
governing bodies
it should apply to all governing bodies
and thank you for pointing that out
okay uh seeing no additional uh
comments
i'd like to thank you for your
participation and
then we're going to hear from the nhma
next thank you so much
well well uh
he's coming to the microphone a question
for the committee
we have two more bills to hear today
after after the
completion of this one
my thoughts are to recess one of them
and that leaves us with one bill
and so the question is do you want to
plow through
and hit that bill and then call it a day
or do you want to take a lunch break and
come back
follow through okay got it
no
mr
mr chairman
will you buy you a candy bar
mr chairman yes
could you tell me which bill we're going
to hear we're going to plow through and
which one we're going to hold we're
going to hear uh hb 1307 okay
and
i'm going to do a hold on hb 12
38.
go ahead mr graves thank you mr chair
nate grace for the new hampshire
municipal association i'll try to be
brief as possible
uh we oppose this bill
i don't think that this bill is workable
as written there are a number of issues
a couple that i wanted to to point out
that weren't uh already pointed out by
the committee today
is the bill as written does not address
rsa 669 colon 71 which addresses
vacancies in the budget committee um
that that statute specifically says that
they're filled under rsa 32 colon 15
romans 7.
obviously this would add a new uh
provision to the budget committee which
is not under roman 7.
under 32 15 roman 7 it's there's a line
that states in municipalities where
members at large are elected vacancies
shall be filled by appointment by the
budget committee
that would seemingly contradict
some of the language provided here in in
the bill is written
as far as the bill
as written goes
as pointed out by representative power
earlier today
it says if a member resigns there's
nothing addressing whether a member dies
whether they move out of town under 32
15 55 anything that would trigger a
vacancy to occur
it's just under a specific instance
um
further
the bill provides the moderator shall
declare the vacancy within 10 days
that's unusual i mean the vacancy occurs
as soon as the person resigns dies
whatever and somebody could be appointed
the next day by
the proper authority um it's strange
that there would be a
a 10-day window here that that would be
required to occur in
um underline five um
i believe the
that the reference to paragraph three
should be paragraph seven romans seven
simply because paragraph three is uh the
provision that provides
how the legislative body determines how
the budget committee is to be
created whether that's appointed or
elected
um
as as the committee addressed uh
numerous committee members addressed
today
lines six and seven about the next
highest number of votes um is just
unclear what happens in the instance of
a write-in or someone who's not
interested or what do you do if you're
on you know the third person on the
ballot um
it seems sort of like this is creating
a variation of ranked choice voting
where the voters don't actually pick
their second choice you just kind of go
to the next one down and that's who gets
filled in
and then lastly um
under lines eight and nine
um
having the the position be listed on the
ballot if there's a resignation during
the filing period is also unusual what
if the resignation is the last day you
have like half an hour to tell everyone
in town there's an opening and so quick
get your your your paperwork in um
that's just not
workable as as a practical matter
um i'm happy to answer any questions the
committee has
any questions
representative
you mr chair thank you mr grace for
taking my question
you kind of answered
part of my confusion in terms of
recruiting you know you brought out the
rank choice
and would it be possible for the
municipalities or the school boards to
have that option
in their bylaws to say rank choice and
you know to begin with there's no
doubt
in terms of
how we are electing so the voters know
when they are electing somebody if it
doesn't work
there is the options that whoever they
elect the second would be so that you
know from the gecko they have that
choice
a ranked choice voting is something the
legislature would have to determine it's
not something we can determine at the
local level okay so going back then so
this is it sorry
so is it
is it possible
that
am i seeing uh that this is what it's
creating
this bill kind of confusing as we
have the voting
there's a parallel universe being
created
well i don't think the bill captures the
intent of the the sponsor my
understanding in speaking with the
sponsor is that the intent was
there
the allegation is there are
circumstances where someone says
hey i know you know joe is running for
the budget committee i don't like joe
i'm already on it i'm going to run again
and then i'll resign the next day after
the election if i win and you guys can
appoint somebody else who's not joe
um i think that's the intent
um
i don't think that's captured by the
legal language here
i'm not
sure i would characterize it as
necessarily the ranked choice voting but
presumably if
a bunch of people in town don't agree
with joe and they learn that the current
budget committee member who's up for
re-election
is going to resign or you know not run
again presumably if enough people like
them someone else will run i mean that's
that's the basis of our democracy
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr grace
that concludes the hearing on
hb 1259 how many online or supported
four five oppose 11. okay thank you
bear with me
okay those who
support and oppose hb 1307 we have
five in support and 29 that oppose
no neutrals
representative griffin would you like to
introduce the bill
thank you very much thank you mr chair
um
and good morning i think still oh no
good afternoon to members of the
committee um thank you for your
indulgence and listening to me in
regards to hb 1307 which was sent to
your committee and it is an act
modifying
the duties of the housing appeals board
this committee is
for the most part i know very familiar
with the housing appeals board
and the core issue in regards to housing
issues in all legislation before us in
regards to these issues is a familiar
one in many areas
and that is the interests of the state
as compared to the interest of our local
communities
and as this bill touches on one fairly
broad area that's in all of our
communities zoning
it was a very controversial proposal and
in fact
passed
into it was 2019 legislation that became
effective in in july july 1st 2020
and it passed in a methodology that is
used by both parties
used and abused i would say in regards
to both parties in regards to being
attached to something else
so we have it
and the fact it came into existence has
not prevented legislation
uh being proposed in regards to it my
bill is one of four that were proposed
this year directly to deal with this
issue for some reason your committee got
one of the bills the three other ones
went to judiciary
the three other bills relating to the
housing appeals for two directly one
indirectly one proposed abolishment of
it
one proposed significant modifications
throughout the body of the statute
dealing with the housing appeals board
and one was a proposal to create a
special court in the superior court
system to deal with housing appeals
those will all be coming to the floor
with a recommendation from the committee
of itl
that doesn't mean that the board is not
without controversy to this day
and my proposal is very simple i can
tell you there are many other parts of
the bill in the housing appeals board
that i disagree with and i continue to
disagree with
however what i have sought to do in this
bill is to address the issue of
jurisdiction
jurisdiction and who can decide what is
something that's needed both for people
who have an issue to be decided and i
think it's needed also for the people
who are doing the deciding
and that's where we get into trouble we
have many arguments or discussions in
this legislature over whether people are
properly deciding things whether they
have been given the authority to do what
they're doing and quite honestly
the decision-making authority
jurisdiction authority in the statute
that's been giving to the housing
appeals board allows for them to decide
anything
that can in any way be related to
housing to include
what your municipality has decided
permit fees should be
whether requirements for fire and safety
are appropriate for the plan as approved
or whether or not a class six road
should be developed or not
developed and i would suggest to you
that why proponents while proponents of
the housing appeals board have said well
that's exactly what it was intended to
do it was proposed to be all
encompassing
what i heard and what i think most
people heard was that developers were
complaining that your local boards who
are elected you just got to talk about
elections most of whom are elected
conservation commissions are not elected
they're appointed but they have certain
decision-making authority
that they're abusing their discretion
they're making decisions that are
improper they're taking too long they're
holding up our our decision-making we
need another avenue
when we have a dispute with what your
board did again you will hear
that's not what we said we said it would
be anything
we all know there's a difference between
what is said and what is heard and if
they said that i didn't hear it
and my apologies to them but it is my
opinion of being a local elected
official for over 30 years that that is
what the appropriate jurisdiction for
this board should be as it is designed
and as it was represented so all my bill
proposes to do
is to modify the proposed language
to make it clear that decisions that it
will hear
are from planning boards zba's building
code of appeals historic district
commissions heritage commissions and
applications for the development of
housing
so
certain regulations
ordinances
or
anything else because it's not limited
to the list that's currently there
would clearly then not be appealable
now
the board has been in place since 2020
you can go on their website and the
decisions are published which is a great
thing when they first started they were
not publishing their decisions
apparently there was some controversy
but they're up there
i can tell you goffstown has one pending
guy i am a representative from goffstown
my apologies i didn't actually introduce
myself
i'm barbara griffin from goffstown um we
had a zba decision appeal that was
affirmed and we had a zba decision that
was not affirmed and has been remanded
for further hearing
i would say a review of the decision of
the housing appeals board indicates that
when it's a smaller application or an
individual application they sort of are
tending to uphold the decision of the
local board or deciding board
that when it they tend to be bigger
applications they tend to overturn
or find something improper in the
decision of the community and remand it
back for further decision
or reverse it entirely depending it so
you will hear some people say hey there
really haven't been that many complaints
we've had 15 plus decisions it's going
pretty well why would we want to change
it let's have a study commission in a
few years
to look at all the decisions and decide
if we need to cut it back
i will tell you this is my eighth year
in the legislature and as i said i've
been on municipal boards for many years
it is much harder to cut things back
than it is to expand them
it is much easier to make a board work
appropriately when the jurisdiction is
clear and there's no question about
whether or not it should be hearing
something
than it is to get into arguments about
whether or not a a particular issue
should have even been before them in the
first place
so
that's all my bill is trying to do
um it's to clearly define
the basis of an appeal to the housing
appeals board which is an unelected
board overseeing decisions of your
elected community members
overseeing decisions related to your
communities adopted by vote zoning
regulations
i'm not trying to get rid of it i'm not
setting up a new court it is here i have
resigned myself to it even though i
don't particularly like it i think the
legislature should be much more honest
and abolish local zoning and enact state
zoning and wouldn't that be fun in your
communities
because that's sort of what we're aiming
for
but that's a discussion
for the cafeteria not here
so um i re i request your support
in regards to this bill i think it is a
reasonable clarification of the current
statute that's consistent with the
majority of decisions and i believe you
will hear that there is dispute as to
whether or not something they heard was
appropriate
and requests that you recommend
and i'd be happy to take any questions
mr chair thank
you representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
bringing this forward representative
griffin
uh i have really two questions one
uh
is
do you could you give me the and the
numbers of the bills that are before the
judiciary i have them i i do not have
them but i will get that i can get that
they were voted last
thursday i can find them anyway you know
follow up mr truman did i hear you
correct that those bills were coming out
of the committee itl correct
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so i i wanted
to
understand and make clear that on line
it says that
applications
for the development of housing
so is it's a prerequisite then that
the
party must have
actually applied and have a bonafide
application
and that
the the party appealing to the housing
board housing appeals board is not
simply thinking about
filing an application and the reason i
ask this is because
currently in brookline a developer has
filed a claim in superior court
with a grievance about the town of
brookline using an innovative land use
control which is
permissible under statute and they have
not actually filed an application
they're just thinking about it they were
exploring it so could you make clear
that
under the amended language
the party
appealing to the housing appeals board
must be in fact
a bona fide applicant thank you
representative and yes i will confirm
that and i think that's a perfect
example of why this bill is needed an
innovative land use control
is something very different than an
application that is before a board to
address
and as a representative just indicated
they chose to go to this the superior
court to the court of equity
which i would suggest is where the
person is that should be deciding that
type of a thing
as compared to whether a community
applied its standards
appropriately or whether those standards
were proper in connection with the
development of housing
my question would would be
does for example a developer do they
have standing to to either go to the
housing appeals board or the superior
court if in fact they have not filed
an application
that they're trying to appeal i would
argue under the current language of the
housing appeals board they would be able
to um
i think people might differ
your particular example they have
clearly chosen to go to superior court
and my change would not prohibit them
from doing that
there there is just no way to avoid that
disputes occur and sometimes they're
going to end up in court depending what
the interests of the parties are and i
think the housing appeals board was
intended to
expedite resolution of issues related to
the actual development of housing not
deal with questions as to whether or not
something was appropriately adopted
which belong in the equity court of the
superior court
all right
further questions for the representative
thank you very much thank you mr chair
thank you members of the committee
next uh like to hear from senator bob
guida
senator guida i'm sorry
i've been called names none of those
letters so i take no offense thank you
mr chairman members of the committee for
the record bob guide to representing
senate district two
and prime sponsor of the bill that
established the housing appeals board
i sent each of you a
an email last evening or maybe this
morning
and i'm going to pass out to the
committee
a copy of one of the decisions rendered
by the housing appeals board that would
not have been possible
had not
had the changes recommended by
representative griffin
been in place if you don't mind
housing appeal board has received a lot
of review by both chambers
and senate passed senate bill 557
on march 15th of 2018.
that's almost four years ago
the house recommended a bill for interim
study
and then recommended it for future
legislation
on a vote of 20 to two out of the
committee
number of senators reintroduced the bill
in the 2019 session
we did this because
as you must be aware
we are in a desperate housing shortage
in our state desperate is the
appropriate word
we are
tens of thousands of housing units short
of what's needed
and
this not only affects
working families this also affects
homeless think about that there's no
housing available for working families
there's certainly no housing available
for the homeless
so it exacerbates a problem
that we face every day as well
the house version of the housing appeals
board was introduced by representative
lynn ober
through house bill 104 they urged
support for the senate version instead
of the house version
the bill was itled
on a voice vote
the senate election law municipal
affairs committee recommended that
senate bill 306 ought to pass
it was then heard by the finance
committee and received an ought to pass
command recommendation six to zero in
the senate
we passed it on a roll call vote of 18
to five in the senate
and senator dallas andrew then chair of
the finance committee requested it be
tabled and addressed within the budget
despite my vigorous protestations to the
contrary because i believe that the bill
shouldn't be used as a political tool
to effectuate political outcomes this
the issue is much much too important
the language from that bill was then
included in house bill 2
which after the governor's veto then
morphed into house bill 4.
the appeals board was discussed during
the committee of conference for the
fiscal 20-21 budget
conferees agreed to the request
and we moved forward to 21.
the appropriation of 415 000 is included
in the final version there had been an
attempt to cut the finding to disable
completely the board
now the reason for the protest and the
the uprising frankly amongst planning
and zoning boards
is that for decades
they have been unsupervised
and for decades they have been violating
state statutes their own local
ordinances as well
if you review and i i gave you in the
email i sent to you the links to the
housing appeals board website
they have so far delivered
rulings on 15 projects that were brought
and appealed
expedited i might add not taking a year
or two or three but within 180 days
in 13 of those 15 appeals
the towns were found to have violated
state statutes
violated their own ordinances
or simply made it up as he went along
because as you know for a body to act it
needs to be authorized to act by
ordinance and the town did not pass
ordinances allowing them to make the
decisions they did
i will not ascribe motives that's not
productive
but we have a definite problem
when a developer or an individual has to
go to superior court
and waste
thousands sometimes tens of thousands
sometimes hundreds of thousands of
dollars
and what de facto then becomes
the end of the project because investors
don't want to spend money on lawyers
they or
on court costs and they can't afford to
wait two or three years for court
decision
okay they want to return on investment
and we need those investments to house
the population of the people of the
state when you talk to the bea you talk
to taylor caswell commissioner caswell
he'll tell you that time after time we
have businesses coming to new hampshire
wanting to work in our great environment
and they don't come here because we
don't have housing
this bill attempts to remedy the
timeliness
it saves towns money instead of having
to go to court and hire lawyers you can
represent yourselves pro se
and it gets you a decision expeditiously
on an issue when you read these
decisions from the housing appeals board
you will see that they reference
state statutes
zoning board and planning board
ordinances that have been passed and
they
articulate the violations they support
it with case law
okay these are carefully thought through
let's talk about the members of the
board for a second they're appointed by
the supreme court
okay
some might go wow well the supreme court
also appoints members of the bureau of
tax and land appeals
that was the agency that we modeled this
legislation after it's very effective
gets the job done it takes a citizen
doesn't have to go to court but still
can after the fact
as in our bill you have two channels if
you get to the end of the road with your
local land use boards you can either go
to superior court or you can go to the
housing appeals board
if you go to the housing appeals board
you don't like the outcome and oh by the
way abutters can do it as well
and oh by the way they have to use the
same process the same rules
as a superior court okay
and so
you get to the end of the road and you
don't like the outcome you can appeal to
the supreme court
now the supreme court doesn't have to
take your case
but i would submit to you that since
it's the supreme court that offers i'm
sorry that that appoints the members of
the committee
subject to approval okay
they would probably understand that the
members that they appointed had made
decisions
okay and they'll look at this before
they decide not to to accept the case
but we've we've laid the path so that we
have an expeditious less costly appeal
through the housing appeals board that
nonetheless
can be taken to court if either side
doesn't agree with the outcome
again i i come back and i urge you to go
to the website
for the housing appeals board and read
through the decisions they're not
arduous okay some of them are you know
six seven eight pages
but read through the conclusions that
they draw
the laws that they stipple that they
cite
and and the ordinances that are violated
and you'll understand the purpose of
this board in no way and the actual
actions of the board in no way truncate
restrict or reduce local control
they just merely make certain
that that local control is in compliance
with the laws of the state of new
hampshire the ordinances of the
community and the case law that has been
derived they're from
this is a this is a bad bill 1307 will
will truncate
the
ability of the housing appeals board to
look at decisions for shall we say
conservation commission
shall we say the fire marshal or the
town fire chief
notoriously in one case
the fire chief decided he wanted an
extra driveway that would have cost
about two hundred thousand dollars and
that killed the project
and so we lost a number of housing units
that would have worked just fine in one
of our communities
so to restrict it to specific language
that restricts the actual
agencies that the housing appeals board
can oversee
you essentially gut the ability of the
board to have the broad purview that it
needs
to look at any rulings that come out of
local use boards or other officials
okay
that in fact deny programs from going
forward and in this case with 1307
would in fact deny the ability to review
them without going to court
i ask you to itl this bill
read the decisions of the housing
appeals board and let's get some housing
responsibly brought forward to the
people of new hampshire thank you mr
chairman
thank you would you stay and take some
questions certainly
all right questions for the senator yes
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question so
to be clear
in the framework or the bill of the bill
lines 6 through 13
a through f that struck
does that imply that these types of
appeals
shall only have the the avenue of
appealing and being heard by the
superior court is that correct
anything that's outside planning board
zoning boards of adjustment building
code boards appeals historic commissions
heritage commissions
would then be required to go to superior
court
incurring delays and expenses that would
otherwise not be incurred
and if heard by the housing appeals
board would still have the right
to litigate
representative
thank you chairman thank you senator uh
so
i had a question oh
i know
so part of the purpose it seems to be
here
is to
make it impossible to use the housing
appeals boards
over issues of fire marshals building
inspectors uh
the road agent
is that your understanding of of this
intent
i can't speak to the intent of the of
the framer and i i streamlessly try to
avoid that
i just look to the effects that the bill
would have and that's exactly what would
happen
follow-up yes
and do we see in new hampshire that
uh
i'm going to try not to characterize it
actions of the fire marshal building
inspector and road agent do
sometimes in fact
restrict housing without improving
safety
i have seen that happen
in my community and then i represent 27
towns pretty big districts so i guess
i've seen that happen
and again that's in no way in no way
truncates the authority
of these individuals it just makes
certain that they're acting within
statutory or ordinance authority that's
established by law
thank you thank you ma'am any other
questions for the senator yes
representative
thank you mr chair thank you senator
for taking my question
at the beginning of your testimony you
alluded to the fact that in fact we are
in a housing crisis in new hampshire it
is a crisis
and
in
you you know reading it it definitely
does not
help
solve the problem that we have on hand
which is a
shortage of acute
so is that the perspective from your
angle to this particular
bill will hinder
solution to creating more housing
i'm not sure i understand your question
um it
we have had several housing bills today
and you know we're trying to solve an
issue which is a crisis level in our
state over 20 000 units shortage
so from looking at from that angle of
providing housing that's much needed
housing for everybody across the board
this bill will hinder
any
solution
that we would bring because it
establishes a very elaborate
process
that would be my assessment of the
impact
by denying the housing appeals board
oversight over decisions made by
entities or individuals not mentioned
specifically in 1307 so yes
thank you
yes
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
one of the things that we've been
hearing uh this session is that we are
lacking housing as representative
manager putin said
um but
essentially or more keenly in
moderate to low-income housing
this bill or does this bill address that
or is it just all the housing in the
world
well i'm i'm going to have to be very
frank you've heard of snob zoning
i
will refer to a senator in the last
session who on her website stated we
like our prestige communities
and the inference is we don't want that
kind of person here
right that's not a new hampshire that's
not that's not a set of values that i
ascribe to
okay
and by denying this is workforce housing
some of it uh is for uh those on lower
economic spectrum
most of it is for those that are working
families okay
and again
uh by by reducing
the the
um the authority or the scope of the
authority of the board
you then begin to truncate its ability
to mitigate the process and the problem
uh so yeah i think i think that would be
a fair assessment thank you
senator yes represent representative
matt
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question when the planning
board which i sit on and have sat on for
10 years and take my responsibility
extremely seriously
um when we sit on there we take into
into account all of the aspects that go
into that site plan
uh that includes uh recommendations from
or
reviews from the fire department
we we look at water we look at runoff we
look at state statutes we look at we
look at we look at
how does this with the development of
housing which would include everything i
assume that goes into that review
that same review
in your opinion does this then say i
cannot look at those things that the
development of housing is so narrowly
restricted
that i can only look at
what
because when i'm sitting on excuse me so
i'll leave my question at that no so and
your point is well taken but
the duties of the planning board are
generally stipulated by ordinance we
have a planning board in our town we
have limited them to lot line
adjustments and subdivision approvals
and that's it
okay there are many communities that go
much farther than that there are
communities in which the opinions of the
fire marshal express to the board of
selectmen
uh if in fact you read the decision i
handed out
board of selectmen is not mentioned in
this bill
and there are other agencies and and
individuals within local community
government who would be able to opine
and over whose opinion the board would
not have jurisdiction
because of the way that local community
has set up its structure
thank you senator
very much oh i'm sorry representative
tripp
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
you made in the uh
you cited an example of where
the
fire chief or something
was going to require
a additional road
uh
in
the town that i live in that would be
considered i think a condition of
approval is that correct
if that's what your town does yes oh
right and this is so
so the uh
the housing appeals board has the
authority to to look at everything like
that
under current law it does
because
it seems that
they're not disapproving
the development they're just citing what
they would consider a
uh
aspect that must be included is that
correct
that would be correct
all right thank you
and i think i think if i may uh
again
i think 1307 would dangerously restrict
the scope of the housing appeals board
there are communities have other
formed agencies boards or whatever
conservation commissions those types of
things
uh whose purview
would not be
overseeing what the board does it takes
a look at the decision in light of and
only in light of
existing laws statewide local ordinances
and case law and it says you know what
and two of these 15 cases he said you
know what town is right
but in 13 of 15 cases
they found that the town violated state
law local ordinances or case law which
was the court's you know interpretation
of a particular case outcome
so i ask you to go itl on this bill
hab is not broken
it doesn't need fixing but our housing
situation surely does thank you mr chair
thank you senator very much appreciate
your time today and
good luck with the rest of your day
next we're going to hear from
representative marjorie porter
welcome back representative
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee it's good to see you all again
representative man you can leave the
room if you need to
okay um and thank you for allowing me to
speak with you today i'm not going to
take very long um you know
my strong feeling about the need for
housing in this state
and you know that i am one of the
sponsors of
establishing the housing appeals board
so i am biased
i'm also the wife of a planning board
member 20-year planning board member
chair and for the duration of the
emergency orders
the town planning board meetings were
held
out of my office in my home
so i was able to listen to the process
and understand
what my husband was trying to get across
to the members of the public and also to
the members of his board and he is a
strong proponent of if you follow the
rules
things go better
as a matter of fact the town lawyer has
praised our cleaning board because when
they do go to court the town always wins
because they follow their own rules
the
housing appeals board
does not
change
town ordinances it does not change the
law
it does not
overrule
a bad decision
if the decision was made
following
the ordinances and the regulations that
the town has established and the rsas
that the state has established
what it does do is make a faster process
so people can go in and get there get
their
appeal heard quickly
it
speeds things up the people that are on
that board are all land use experts so
to speak they have a great deal of
knowledge which you might not always get
in the superior court when you go in
with a thing like this before the
housing appeals board those judges might
not have a lot of land use and municipal
law experience
but the appeals board uses the same
standards that the court used and the
appeal the people who lose or win have a
chance to go to the supreme court
afterwards if they're not happy so it's
it's working people are satisfied
they're moving things through
we need to be able to get things done in
a speedy way to get housing that we need
in this state so i hope you will
consider itling this bill um it's
and i'll take any questions that you
have any questions for the
representative yes representative
thank you mr c thank you uh my friend
and colleague
for taking my question
um so
you are very succinct in saying so this
bill is basically shifting
the local control
to the courts
is that what
in a nutshell that i'm
understanding
i'm not sure that it's shifting the
local control because the ordinances are
are determined by the town or the city
and the
the land use board is supposed to follow
those ordinances that the voters have
approved so if the land use board has
followed those ordinances and there's an
appeal
and it goes to the the housing appeals
board
if the town has followed the rules and
their own ordinances then they will get
a a ruling in their favor if they have
not
if you know joe over here wants to
manipulate it a little bit because his
friend harry is the one that's doing the
development then that's might not fly
and that's the function of this board
thank you i mean you're making it uh i
didn't frame my question properly you
answered it in a way
okay that was the question in my mind
was that
what we have currently is working well
in terms of having the overseeing board
and the local control
and this would flip it on the head
it could possibly do that yes thank you
thank you any other further questions
for the representative
seeing none thank you
good to see you
like to call up ben frost
thank you mr chairman
i'm ben frost from new hampshire housing
i'm here to
express new hampshire housing's
opposition to this and we request that
you i recommend itl
i can't really improve upon the
testimony provided by representative
porter and senator gaida they thoroughly
went through the purposes of the housing
appeals board and why
um it should be kept as it is
i do want to emphasize a couple things
um
one is that when when i remember hearing
probably last year or the year before
when
uh the housing appeals board was the
legislation was pending there was a
statement that
the authority is ambiguous it's it is
not ambiguous it is clear
it is about local decisions decisions of
local
boards committees and commissions that's
the statute boards committee synthesis
and commissions on housing and housing
development and it refers to final
decisions
of boards committees and commissions
um so representative power you you asked
the question about the the brookline
litigation i'm familiar with that
litigation
no local board committee or commission
made a decision in that case
that involved the adoption of a new
zoning provision by the town of
brookline that is not i believe within
the jurisdiction of the housing appeals
board that resides exclusively within
the courts
uh the effect
that this uh that house bill 1307 would
have
uh would be to
push more of these issues back to the
courts
right now you can take these questions
these local decisions
either to superior court or to the
housing appeals board
so if you have a decision of a planning
board or a zoning board or an historic
district commission
which is within the bill as presented to
you
those those can be taken to superior
court or they can be taken to the
housing appeals board
under the current law
there are other decisions of other
boards
that currently can go to the housing
appeals board
that would no longer be able to be
appealed to the housing appeals board
should house bill 1307 become law
and
senator gaida circulated a decision i
think it's evans versus the town of
pembroke which involves the decision of
a
local select board the board of
selectmen on the question of whether to
reclassify a class six highway to class
five
um
if house bill 1307 were law
that could not go to the housing appeals
board even though
by its own terms the select board of the
town of pembroke made it about housing
that would no longer be appealable to
the housing appeals board
and in that case uh the the housing
appeals board reviewed what the select
board in
pembroke did
found that they had not applied the
proper legal standard and remanded it
gave them a second chance and on remand
under the advice of legal counsel
the select board in pembroke changed
their decision
allowing
the process to continue this is a not
even a proposed development yet it's
something that was in the minds of the
landowner but they needed to change the
road classification in order to be able
to proceed with the development
then allowing it to go to the planning
board which could consider all of the
things that uh representative measure
you you brought up uh so you know the uh
the law as it stands the law and and the
bill as proposed would not have any
impact on the scope of decisions that
the planning board can make and whether
they could be reviewed by the housing
appeals board so everything that a
planning board does
that is currently appealable to the
housing appeals board would still be
appealable to
the housing appeals board if house bill
1307 became law that's not the issue
here it's not the planning board
decisions it's not the zoning board
decisions it's the decisions of other
unenumerated boards
committees and commissions that would be
cut out and shunted back to the court
system as opposed to being able to be
taken to the housing appeals board the
housing appeals board as senator guida
said is not broken so don't fix it
it is i believe
doing as the legislature intended
hearing these appeals efficiently and
effectively in a way that neither favors
developers nor nor
property owners nor the municipalities
northern butters all parties are equal
before the housing appeals board so for
these reasons i
respectfully request you to recommend
itl on house bill 1307 and be happy to
take any questions
yes representative vann
i'm sorry
i am still a representative and
uh thank you chairman
thank you mr frost mr frost um i was
just thinking about what you said about
the planning boards and so forth and so
on is it your sense that the existence
of the housing appeals board
has made
land use boards more careful
about
abiding by their own ordinances
representative that's an excellent
question and i think
when
when i was testifying a couple of years
ago before this committee on this issue
i think that was a hope that i expressed
i can't say that after just a year of
hearing cases that that has had that
effect
although i suspect that where
um a
municipality a local board has had an
issue remanded
by the housing appeals board and they've
been given the opportunity to do it
right the second time they have made
better decisions witness uh in the the
town of pembroke the select board's
decision in other situations they're not
remanded uh because there's no reason to
and i think you know
when when a when a board loses
because they made a bad decision i hope
it's a learning experience
there are plenty of examples in the
courts and the housing appeals board too
where local boards have simply made bad
decisions they haven't provided adequate
uh you know findings in support of their
decisions or they've applied the wrong
standard of law
you know those those are appropriately
reversible and
if you know the if the
local board is paying attention
i hope that they would take some lessons
from it
and make better decisions in the future
thank you
okay well thank you mr fry oh i'm sorry
one more representative tripp
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question
uh
i noticed one other thing that's in in
this bill is that the uh
in order to go before the uh housing
assessment board housing appeals appeal
board uh you have to have made an
application
i i i think
some of the things that you said is
people developers are
can make use of the board to
test run
decisions
it's uh you said in the brookfield co
case uh the selectmen
uh made a decision not to change the the
type of road and uh
the developer went to the
house
the board to try that out
is is this
what the uh
the the board was
set up for
let me um go back to
to validate or dis validate uh these
types of conditions
well representative uh you you've asked
a question that i think combines a
couple of different things first off
it's the language of house bill 1307
that talks about applications yes the
the current law
as it stands talks about final decisions
so however you get
a local board to have made a final
decision on something uh whether it's
and i think this typically would be
through applications so you file an
application for a subdivision or site
plan review with the planning board you
file an application with the board of
adjustment for a variance or a special
exception
you file an application for
a
building permit with the building
inspector that then gets appealed to the
local building code board of appeals
which is then all of those are then
appealable to
the housing appeals board if they deal
with housing
so they all involve an application
but they that the key
is not the fact of the application the
key
where the housing appeals board
jurisdiction begins
is with the final decision of that board
whether it's a an application that's
been brought to them or
in the case of
a road reclassification it's a request
presented to
the select board i know there's not a
there's not a form i don't think that
most municipalities have that's that
calls for road reclassification so it's
not not an application but it is a
request that is made to
the select board so
whether there is a formal application
that's on a sheet of paper or online
or it's a request
is not really the issue under current
law it's the fact that a local board
committee or commission has made a final
decision
on something that's been presented to it
regarding housing and housing
development that's where the housing
appeals for jurisdiction begins
representative
thank you chairman again thank you mr
frost
so
my understanding is that the housing
appeals board exists
uh as sort of a statewide zoning board
of appeals you had to you had to go
through the application process whatever
it is whether it's asking the select
board or whomever
and a decision was rendered i presented
my project it got turned down for
reasons that i consider to be specious
therefore
i can go to the housing appeals board
i can't look
at your code
and
ask the housing appeals board to render
a judgment on whether your town's
adopted code is or is not good for
what i want to do i have to go all the
way through the process
and get turned down before i can go to
the appeals board is that correct
it it is but i would disagree with your
characterization of the housing appeals
board as a statewide okay
i was trying to think about what could i
describe and let me explain the
distinction because it's very important
a local board of adjustment the zoning
board of adjustment
hears cases de novo
it's they they're starting over they're
putting themselves in the place of the
original decision maker whether it was
the planning board decision that gets
appealed to the zba or the select board
or the building inspector decision that
gets appealed to the zba it's de novo
meaning
they are starting over
appeals to superior court and to the
housing appeals board of the decisions
of a cpa or a planning board are on the
record they are not de novo they take
the certified record from the
municipality they don't generally
speaking take new evidence
this is a really important
legal distinction
between
what the the zba does locally and what
the court
or the housing appeals board either one
does at the the state level if you will
uh it is
um there's great deference is provided
by the
court and by the housing appeals board
to local decisions they're not looking
to overturn they're looking to support
the decision unless it was unreasonable
or contrary to law that's the standard
thank you mr frost
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
frost for taking my question
um when you go to the housing appeal
board's website they list
they list matters that are that you can
appeal
and they reference the statute which
lists matters that you can appeal
but in the statute it lists and you know
one of one of the members of my planning
board mr well a gentleman who
states that if you have to write it down
you've immediately lost the battle
because you can never write everything
down that is included
so the statute includes the little
phrase but is not limited to
can you please tell me who decides
what the limits are
in the appeal
in the first and thank you for that very
good question uh in the first instance
it would be the housing appeals board
to decide whether it was in within their
jurisdiction the same way a court makes
the a decision so is it within their
power to hear
the matter before them do they have
what's called subject matter
jurisdiction
that that is a a the initial threshold
question
that any appellate body has to ask
itself
do we have subject matter jurisdiction
to hear this thing whatever it is
so it's the the court or the housing
appeals board the the the question is
the same do we have subject subject
matter jurisdiction and so the housing
appeals board looks to the statute
and sees these things and if it's not
enumerated you're right there's this
other phrase
includes but is not limited to so then
they have to interpret more broadly is
this something about housing and housing
development is it within the broader
structure of rsa chapter 679 the housing
appeals board statute if the answer is
yes then they find that they have
jurisdiction if the answer is no they
don't have jurisdiction and they don't
hear the case
if one of the parties disagrees with
that decision
that decision is appealable
to the supreme court and the supreme
court does hear these questions not they
haven't yet heard a housing appeals
board appeal i don't think although
there may have been one one or two that
have had oral arguments already but no
final decisions
um
but there it's a very frequent question
for the supreme court to hear on appeal
from a trial court decision is there
subject matter jurisdiction and if the
answer is no
then the then the decision where court
did proceed uh was made erroneously
see no further questions thank you mr
frost it's a pleasure to be back with
you
likewise
mr will stewart are you still here
thank you for your patience
it's our scheduling
floor is yours thank you so much mr
chairman members of the committee again
will stewart executive director of stay
work play new hampshire
statewide nonprofit whose mission is to
attract and retain more young people as
in my previous testimony on a previous
bill you know we are very supportive of
legislation that seeks to make housing
more affordable here in new hampshire
because that again is the number one
barrier to attracting and retaining
young people here in the granite state i
don't have more to add certainly than um
than the sponsor of this bill then mr
frost and senator gaida all spoke to it
uh to a degree and knowledge and
specificity which i couldn't begin to
approach i will however say that uh we
are in opposition you to this bill and
likewise would like to see it itild
thank you any questions
yes
representatives
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question as i understand the
housing appeals board has absolutely
nothing to do with affordability
um it is simply
a method where a developer can appeal a
planning board decision but that that
decision may be about a development of
multi-million dollar homes
i think it
as i understand it you're right it could
run the gamut you know any type of you
know housing uh i will say you know
while it might not be direct there is
certainly a correlation in your supply
and demand again as i spoke on a
previous bill you know we need more
supply and that it's you know the supply
is being i think artificially uh
and in some cases deliberately
suppressed in in some towns in this
state uh that are contravening their own
ordinances and state law you know to not
allow you know certain types of housing
particularly housing of the rental
variety and that might be probably more
affordable to younger people in
particular that we represent but all
granite staters
follow up mr chairman
are you aware of any
decisions that the housing appeals board
has rendered with respect to affordable
housing developments
i am not personally i would defer to uh
you know people who are have more
expertise in the board itself thank you
okay uh thank you appreciate your
testimony
next we'll hear from natch grace in the
nhma
thank you mr chairman h grace for the
new hampshire municipal association
we support this bill um it will be very
brief i thank attorney frost for
summarizing the effects of the bill i i
agree with
his characterization that this is really
about determining what the scope of the
housing appeals board should be
we obviously disagree with his position
and we think it should be limited
um
and
our
contention is really um against that uh
that court decision that i believe
senator guida handed out which i believe
to be the evans versus town pembroke
decision
where
the housing appeals board heard the
appeal over whether to reclassify a
class 6 road as a class 5 road
we don't view that as something that
that would relate to questions of
housing and housing development
which is the purpose of the board
i understand there's disagreement about
that i'm certainly happy to answer any
questions the board
that the committee has any questions yes
representative
thank you mr chair
um thank you for taking my
question
i'm a little puzzled
road you give an example of road
isn't that the infrastructure needed for
development
and so
if
development of a home or a community
and so if that was one of the things
that
makes you
makes the nhma support this bill and
negates everything else
so
the
justification doesn't die for me so i'm
just trying to
right so
as uh as attorney frost um
briefly summarized um
the question the case was just whether
to reclassify the road
and
a large amount of the discussion ended
up being well will there be future
development on the road and how will
that affect the municipality
but it wasn't like
it wasn't as if there was an application
to put that development in place
and part of that was
a
rebuilding of the road or reclassified
or something like that so it wasn't
it wasn't as tangentially attached to
housing as we believe that it should be
i hope that clarifies things i'm not
sure i did though
but
how do i frame it
your justification for support
seems very weak
to me
in terms of housing so in you know in
context to the housing so
that's just my response i understand
your position
representative gilman yes thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um
let's see how to
would you say that the uh currently
existing
rsa versus the
bill that's introduced
would
um
change the question of which board sees
the case first and and um for example
does an hdc
go to the planning board first or does
the planning board go to the hdc
vice versa so one of them says yes i can
do this when they go to the second board
would you see that this um helps that no
no the way i would see it is
so currently the housing appeals board
takes
any question that they think relates to
housing and
the statute is written doesn't
really have a definition it has a list
of examples and then says anything else
that relates to housing
what the bill would do
is simply limit to appeals from
municipal land use boards so you know
what boards can appeal to the hab and
which ones can't um so if it was
something
you know to continue to use my road
example
if it was the case that a
developer was coming in they were
building a
proposing a development and part of that
proposal included
an upgrade to a road
and that fell under the planning board's
jurisdiction
that would be appealable to the hab but
if it was just somebody came in and said
hey i live on a classic sword i want you
to clap reclassify that as a class five
road and that's a question before the
select board that would not be
appealable to the hab thank you
okay thank you uh mr graves oh i'm sorry
mr representative tripp
thank you mr chairman hiding behind that
anyhow
is it
true to say that the major flaw
with the current existing law is that
the
housing appeal
board
uh is is just unbounded
that's our position yes
thank you
okay uh
thank you uh thank you
next uh alyssa margolin are you still
here
welcome and sorry for the delay
the committee my name is alyssa margalyn
i serve as director of housing action
new hampshire we're a statewide
coalition of 80 organizations united
around affordable housing policy and
ending homelessness in new hampshire
housing action new hampshire opposes
house bill 1307
but we do really welcome this
opportunity to address broader concerns
about the housing appeals board clarify
the origins
and debunk some of the myths that have
been circulating about the board
we found that our discussions with house
judiciary and those bills that were
mentioned earlier house bill
and
house bill 1254 that were recently
recommended itl by house judiciary 18-3
that having
these hearings actually helped
understand what the housing appeals
board is and what it is not
so
one of those
one of the
ways to understand how affordable
housing developers so the members of
housing action new hampshire are those
who develop manage finance affordable
housing properties supportive housing
providers homeless service agencies and
public housing agencies
and it's important to recognize i think
that's been noted already is that we
were one of a broader group of
stakeholders this is not just about
affordable housing it's about all
housing
another thing is about the history of
the legislation about this idea that
somehow this bill was not debated in
this body when in fact it was and i
thought senator guida did a good job
walking through the history of the
legislation
and
so and that's also included in my
written testimony so i won't repeat that
as well
if the
the authors and those who had worked for
many years to uh
to write rsa 679 and to create the
housing appeals board uh wanted to make
sure that this new entity designed you
know based on the model of the btla
would provide this faster review subject
matter expertise but only after local
reviews were exhausted
they wanted to make sure it was clear
couldn't rewrite local zoning or
subdivision regulations or site plan
regulations or master plans this idea
that local control was still at the core
of how we functioned in our state in
fact it was the new hampshire municipal
association
uh in
their legislative bulletin in 2019
reviewed the legislation and said the
board would apply the same law and the
same standards that a judge would apply
so municipality would not be prejudiced
by having an appeal brought to the board
rather than to the court
the there's also this myth that somehow
the benefits of
a faster review only benefits the
applicant but when obviously it can
benefit the defendant as well so cost
savings
um one of the real concerns around this
bill as proposed is that we would be
reopening the door to kind of tactical
use of delay
right that's what we were seeking to
address
so
many um affordable housing developers
never appeal their decisions they cannot
pass on the cost of litigation to their
tenants right and so um
having a faster and less costly review
process where you actually don't even
need to engage an attorney you could use
your your local you know you could use
your engineer your architect even
um
is a real benefit to affordable housing
developers and the question asked
earlier about affordability
um
the the actual decision that senator
guida shared with you earlier the one
that would not have been able to go
before the board
should we have had language as proposed
in 1307 that one was related to an
affordable housing development
um in the end we just urge you not to
reopen the door to gamesmanship we don't
think it's kind of it would be a
a way to kind of circumvent
the the process to say well you know if
i if i
try to kill this project through
something that's not appealable to the
housing appeals board that forced it to
go to superior court i know that i can
therefore impose three years of
litigation and really those types of
delay tactics that kills the affordable
projects way faster than it kills the
other projects so with that we urge you
to itl the bill and thank you very much
for your service and staying for such a
long hearing
any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
and last but not least we have a david
let me say is it juve or juvette
welcome
thank you mr chair members of the
committee recognizing i am the last
person to testify i will keep this very
brief
um i want to make a couple of points um
one is i want to correct a couple of
statements from the bill's sponsor that
i think
were incorrect
one is that she said if you don't pass
this bill you might as well get rid of
local zoning ordinances and just have a
state ordinance for every town that is
not what the housing appeals board is
all about the housing appeals board does
not create local ordinances it looks at
local ordinances and it looks at
existing state law and case law to make
sure the decisions that were rendered
at the local level were rendered
properly
i also want to express a little bit of
surprise with my friends from the
municipal association
supporting this bill and the reason why
is
when this bill was being
vetted discussed when it was conceptual
the municipal association was very much
a stakeholder in this bill now they did
not support the legislation i should be
clear
but they did not oppose it either and i
think part of the reason they didn't
oppose it is we listened to their
concerns
and built language into the legislation
that addressed their concerns
i also think they recognized
the benefit of the housing appeals board
as also being a cost-saving measure for
the town so they don't have to get
dragged into
costly time-consuming legislation
nonetheless they are where they are
i just want to make sure you understand
the connection
between housing and employers in your
communities
housing is a public policy issue for
businesses
was not always on our radar screen i
think it started developing around 2007
2008 when we began hearing from our
members
we're having a hard time hiring people
not because the jobs aren't there and
not because they don't want to work for
us and not because the salary isn't what
they're hoping to find
we're having trouble hiring them because
they can't find housing in our community
so i would ask all of you to go back to
the employers in your communities and
ask them what is your experience right
now hiring are you able to hire people
and if the answer which i think you'll
hear is we're having an extraordinarily
difficult time hiring and it's impacting
our ability to do business ask them if
they think the amount of housing in
their area is sufficient for the number
of people that they need in their
businesses is it sufficient for the
teachers that your schools need is it
sufficient for firefighters and police
that your communities need i think
you'll find out that the answer is no
and this is why the housing appeals
board is so important
to uh
allowing for appropriate housing
development in communities where it is
really needed miss chair thank you i'd
be happy to address any questions the
committee might have yes any questions
for
mr juve
yes representative ron
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
jude uh
first may i ask what organization you're
affiliated with i'm sorry um what a
rookie mistake
i must not have identified myself i'm
the senior vice president for public
policy for the business and industry
association we service new hampshire's
statewide chamber of commerce
we have approximately 400 plus employer
members with over 80 000 employees in
the state okay thank you
any other questions yes representative
mentioned
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
you mentioned
employees employers in our communities
how would you characterize students of
our universities we have universities
where the students are coming housing is
a big issue
for them so
you know university are as an employer
as well as a business
but the
students are also
how would you i mean that's impacting
our state too it's a it's a good
question i guess in the spirit of
transparency i should say that the
university system as an employer is a
member of the bia
um and they certainly
uh
could tell you better than i the housing
challenges that students have
but
candidly i think it's an issue all
around the state for communities
cities larger cities and smaller
communities
for employers to
have the
housing available within a reasonable
commute from the workplace for for their
employees
sorry i didn't it didn't snap to it um
with my earlier question but
um on an earlier bill we heard today um
we had testimony from mr stewart from um
stay work play
and i had asked him if
um the the housing shortage which this
bill would
would affect um
has been keeping businesses from
considering relocation to new hampshire
and he wasn't able to to answer that but
you're probably in a position the bia
where companies that are contemplating
coming to new hampshire
uh might consider that have you has that
been part of your experience it has i
would say
first of all i think uh lack of
available and affordable housing affects
businesses of all size your specific
question i think is
being asked more by larger companies
companies coming in for example i'll
provide an example
before fidelity investments came into
the state
uh you know they've got a huge campus in
merrimack i'm a former merrimack
resident and i was there when they came
in
one of the questions they needed to
answer because they have
i don't know how many employees is but i
believe it's well over a thousand
is if if there was an adequate workforce
in that area to
to fill the number of jobs that they
were going to be bringing in they
decided the answer was yes but they came
in at a time where
um there was
a little bit of a housing glut in in
nevada we had a bit of a housing crash
and that created a lot of open
properties i
remember when i moved to merrimack it
was in 1992 i bought a
four bedroom split level ranch in a very
nice neighborhood for a hundred and ten
thousand dollars i mean a price that you
can't even imagine nowadays especially
in southern new hampshire so it wasn't
as huge an issue at the time the
fidelity came in but it's the type of
question that a lot of larger companies
will answer can
if we choose to move to new hampshire
and there's a lot of positive reasons
why they would want to
but there are some negatives associated
to it one of them is is there going to
be sufficient housing for the number of
employees that we're going to need
any other questions
okay thank you very much thank
you that closes the
hearing on house bill
now i'm going to open the hearing on
house bill 1238
i'm going to recess that bill
and reconvene on february 9th
at 12 30 p.m
have a good day
i'm just gonna clean up my
stuff here
i got more stuff that needs to be thrown
out
thank you
all right
oh you are
going to the hotel
sorry you're wrong
oh
my body
um
there's the tagline
okay
is
thank you
okay